Rogan experience Joe Rogan podcast.
And we're live gentlemen,
here we go again.
What's happening back in the room?
A pleasure to see you guys.
As always.
This is one of my favorite podcasts that
we ever do.
And uh,
this is very timely because first of
all,
the Big New York Times article about the
possibility of a,
a comet hitting Los Angeles.
The preparations for what they would do
if a common hit Los Angeles.
And uh,
the comment,
no one has Donald Trump that's hit the
United States and he's even got the hair
and just the whole thing is,
I mean,
if the end of the world was coming,
boy,
it's all on the wall.
You know,
the writing's all there.
It's kind of crazy.
So what's the latest and the greatest?
Well,
the latest and the latest and the
greatest is like,
I mean last year when we sat down with
you,
I think it was last November.
Yeah,
it was almost a year got floated in the
discussion.
The idea that this really important
comet research that's going on,
which is just changing our whole view of
history and prehistory and of the future
of humanity,
that it would be good to make a film
about this.
And crowdfunded.
I actually mentioned that to the
scientists and they said what we really
need is more funding for our research.
And so they've inspired by basically by
your shell,
they have put out a crowdfunding
campaign,
um,
which is linked on my,
on my website,
it's the comic research group.
Um,
uh,
it's,
it's a big story right now.
So how can people find it really
quickly?
It's indeigogo well researched much
quicker way.
Just go,
just go to my website,
Graham hancock.com
and there's a revolving banner,
which is the comic research group.
Click on that and you're in business.
Beautiful.
Okay.
Graham hancock.com
and then crowdfunding for common
research.
And so what are they you are trying to
put together?
Well,
they're,
they're wanting to,
he said,
the thing is these guys have actually
not had any official funding.
This is a group of major,
highly credentialed scientists who for
the last decade have been investigating
the extraordinary story of a massive
comic series of comic impacts on the
North American ice cap 12,800
years ago.
That is the,
the global cataclysm that wipes out a
whole civilization from,
from prehistory.
So that's why it's of interest to me.
Um,
they're not coming at it from that point
of view.
They're coming at it from rediscovering
something that we've lost about
ourselves.
Something is really important to
understand the role of cataclysms in the
story of the earth and they need to do
much more research.
So they need to go back to greenland
and,
and look for the nano diamonds in the,
in,
in the greenland ice cores they need,
there's a,
there's an ancient city,
which they're not revealing the name of
which they're pretty certain was wiped
out by a comet impact about four and a
half thousand years ago.
They want to go there and investigate
that.
So there's a lot of field work they need
to do to drive home this hypothesis and
to frankly put down the opposition
because there's been so much opposition
to this idea from people with vested
interest in other theories that a,
and that's why these guys have not got
funding,
so the only place they're going to get
funding to do this further research is
from members of the general public and
that's what we're hoping that will will
happen.
It's called the comet research group.
There's a banner on my site and all the
links are there to their crowd funding,
to their website,
which is full of masses of scientific
information and to their facebook page
as well.
It is a very unusual thing,
the the fact that we know that comments
and all sorts of various large objects
have impacted the earth.
We see the craters,
we know they exist,
but it's so rarely discussed.
It's so,
it's so strange.
If it wasn't for this article in the New
York Times,
I can't remember when the last time,
and that even came up and it's such a
huge issue.
It's a massive issue.
It's a massive issue,
both randall and I have really,
you know,
give it a great deal of thought to this.
And I think Randall,
the point is that catastrophes are the
untold story of our past.
We were given a little,
we were given a little hint of it.
Um,
February of 2013.
Chelyabinsk Siberia.
Remember the event?
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
that was just a little cosmic Spec came
in.
I was about 50 feet in diameter,
which is about,
um,
and it came in at a fairly low angle of
blew up nearly 18.
Get that thing right in front of you.
Right in front of me.
Like this.
Yeah.
If you have flat it out,
it's usually easier when there's better.
Yeah.
There we go.
So it,
it came in,
I think it exploded 12 miles,
about 20 kilometers up in the
atmosphere,
but it was still enough to damage
thousands of buildings and injure 1500
people.
Now,
the thing about that one is if it had
been slightly larger,
if it had come in at a slightly steeper
angle,
a little bit higher velocity,
you could have had thousands of
fatalities.
Rather than just injuries.
And that would have been major headline
news at that point as it was.
It's already forgotten.
But you do remember.
Yes.
Oversight.
We may even talk have talked.
I believe we did.
We did.
Yeah.
We showed videos of it.
What's fascinating is a,
Russia has so many of those trail camp
on not trail cam mom,
uh,
Dash Cam photo cameras.
That's right.
Cause they have so much insurance fraud
apparently over there and people slam
into each other all the time and we want
to record it.
So we were fortunate enough to have so
many of those videos because of that,
which puts it on the record.
Whereas other,
otherwise it would,
it would not be,
I think,
I think people don't,
it doesn't like to talk about cataclysms
and catastrophes and actually nor do I,
nobody wants a horrible cataclysm to
occur.
But this is the point which is that the
prospect of a comet or asteroid
cataclysm on the earth is actually much
higher than has been told to us up till
now.
And something can be done about it.
It doesn't have to be the end of the
world.
We don't have to say,
okay,
it's all over.
Forget about it.
Quite the contrary,
this is,
this is just something that would be
prudent and rational for the human
species to do and amongst many other
imprudent and irrational things that we
focus on.
Instead,
we should be focusing on a bit on this
at least just to heighten awareness of
it and and also the possibility that we
been nailed a bunch of times and we've
forgotten about it and this is,
this is the big thing that you've been
dealing with your entire career,
this skepticism about past
civilizations.
I mean,
I got into it with Michael Shermer,
who's a friend of mine who's a very
famous skeptic.
I got into him with it yesterday because
I posted that you were going to be on
and he started chirping something about
civilizations 12,000
years ago.
Where's the evidence on like,
dude,
you don't even,
you're saying this and you don't even
know about gold Beckley tappy so I sent
him,
go back to the tapping.
Literally like five hours later he wrote
something claiming that while that was
made by hunter gatherers,
it was all just really to sort of suit
his narrative.
So he doesn't know that.
No one knows that.
He knows that they are so determined to
keep the existing model and when new
evidence comes in,
which company explained by the existing
model,
they just tried to explain away the new
evidence and not not think,
maybe it's time to change our theory.
You know,
this is,
this is the,
and the unfortunate thing,
but cataclysms a global cataclysm,
the massive event that happened 12,800
years ago,
the younger dryas impact,
which were a series of comet impacts on
the North American ice cap.
This accounts for why we don't have a
lot of evidence,
hard evidence of a 12,000
plus year old civilization because it
went down in that catastrophe was wiped
out.
I've been trying to amass the evidence
actually that compliments what Graham
was doing and it really answers that
question at schermer brought up,
and it's a legitimate question,
where's the evidence?
But I'm quite sure that Schermer is not
really educated in the extreme events
that have really taken place on this
planet in the last 10 to 20,000
years.
Um,
and what that would do to any kind of
evidence.
And maybe while we have some time here
today,
I brought a few things to try to convey
some sense of how extreme some of these
changes of ban and how one would
actually be quite shocked to find
anything existing in the aftermath of
these events.
Well,
Michael Shermer is a brilliant guy and I
don't mean to shit on him,
but,
but what,
what is disturbing to me is that his
knee jerk reaction to this without
having any research at all in the
subject,
not knowing it all about go back like
tabby,
which was discovered in what,
the nineties yeah,
96.
So this is,
to me,
this is something that I've looked at
because of you guys in great depth.
When I read your book,
I was just completely enthralled with
this idea of history,
having some sort of,
uh,
or rise and fall and civilization having
these resets.
So I've been absorbed in it for a long
time.
But what's fascinating to me is people
that consider themselves to be skeptical
or you know,
or I mean he's a skeptic professional
issue,
but many people who question anything
that's outside of what they've been told
as soon as they hear any sort of a
theory outside of what they've been
told,
the immediately call,
quackery and this.
But it's,
it's a weird knee jerk reaction to
something,
especially when you talk about
asteroids,
that is a very real part of our past.
We have a ton of evidence.
I mean there's actual craters that you
can look at on earth.
The moon,
which has no atmosphere is littered with
them.
And if we look at the moon as a model
for what could possibly have happened to
earth,
or at least you know,
some of them,
obviously with the moon having no
atmosphere,
it's going to get hit a lot more than we
are.
But still,
and I mean this is a very real situation
that this,
this solar system,
you know,
it was,
was at least as far as we know the only,
so it was solar system has to deal with
this.
But we know this is a,
this is a real issue.
I mean we've seen impacts which like you
just said,
on one hand you have earth scientists
looking at the earth and what they're
realizing is that the earth is
pockmarked with scars in each of these
scars represents a tremendously powerful
catastrophe,
has happened in the history of the earth
now that's accepted by mainstream
science that that major catastrophes
have happened in the history of the
earth.
But where this thing now is about to
come full circle is the recognition that
these kinds of catastrophes of also
influenced the rise and fall of
civilization and a lot more,
um,
a lot more extremely than,
than has been recognized up to this
point.
And while geologists and
neuroscientists,
scientists are looking at the surface of
the earth in realizing that,
um,
etched into the surface of the earth are
imprinted into the surface of the earth,
are hundreds of scars of which are
undoubtedly are only a small percentage
of the total that exist.
At the same time,
astronomers are looking out into near
space and discovering that we cohabitate
space with a lot of stuff.
It's not as empty as we thought.
And just within the last six or seven
weeks,
we've had two close flybys of previously
undiscovered that have previously
undiscovered asteroids.
This is the plank is NASA keeps saying,
well there's,
you know,
there's,
we've counted 1,650
asteroids and none of them are going to
hit the earth in the next hundred years.
Well,
yeah,
that's true.
But what about all the ones they haven't
counted,
which are estimated to run into hundreds
of thousands in which haven't been seen
yet.
And what happens is we see them roughly
10 days before they passed the earth.
That is not enough time to do anything
about them.
But we have time if we're prepared to be
rational and reasonable as a
civilization to take care of this issue.
Now when you're dealing with hundreds of
thousands of near Earth objects that are
flying around,
like what?
What are the things that could be done
to protect earth?
You can paint.
It's low tech.
Actually you can paint one side of the
asteroid effect.
It's Albido so that the sun's rays push
differentially on one side rather than
the other.
That will shift.
It's all bits slightly.
It has to be calculated.
You can give it a little knock with,
uh,
with,
with a,
a Rockett.
Basically,
you don't want to blow it up.
You don't want to turn,
you know,
your one big piece of artillery shell
into Buckshot.
You don't want to do that.
You want to,
you want to move it into a safer orbit.
You can mount jets on it.
People are looking now to mining
asteroids,
of course,
are our society always goes,
I civilization always goes for the
where,
where the,
where the money's to be made.
But if we can mine asteroids,
we can move as to relates.
And,
and the technology is there.
And ironically,
the most dangerous asteroids are going
to be the ones
that are the closest to the earth,
which are the most accessible.
And the asteroids pretty much have
unbelievable amounts of resources on
them.
I mean,
pretty much everything that is being
mined on the earth can be found in
asteroids from the hydrocarbons to
precious metals to all of these things.
And we're not that far away from
technologically being able to actually,
you know,
mount expeditions to asteroids and mind
them.
And that's,
that's the,
the um,
you know,
that's the solution I kind of prefer
because again,
these things are tremendous sources of
reese,
of,
of all kinds of things that would be
usable to an expanding civilization.
And,
um,
we could feasibly within a decade or two
be mining asteroids and again,
the ones that are the easiest access are
also going to be the ones that are more
dangerous because they're the ones that
are coming to closest to the earth.
So,
and add another point here is that there
is one specific danger.
There's one specific if you like,
region of the sky that really needs to
be looked at and this is,
this is the region of the sky.
This is why I wrote magicians of the
gods because because of this discovery
that there's a thing called the taurid
meteor stream,
which is 30 million kilometers wide and
which envelops the solar system and the
earth on its orbit around the sun passes
through the Taurid meteor stream twice a
year.
Turns out the Taurid meteor stream is
the debris of a giant comment that came
in to the inner solar system about
20,000
years ago.
That thing was at least a hundred
kilometers in diameter according to
their calculations if may have been more
so.
And then like other comments like
shoemaker,
Levy nine which spectacularly hit
Jupiter in 1994 it began to break up
into multiple fragments and those carry
on orbiting on the original path,
which and as they break up more and
more,
they degrade and small bits and large
bits break off and it gradually fills up
a kind of huge hoop of debris that the
earth is passing through twice a year.
It takes us 12 days to pass through it.
We do two and a half million kilometers
a day on our orbital path,
12 days to get through the Taurid meteor
stream and the scientists of of the
comic research group have made the point
that a big object out of the Taurid
meteor stream multiple objects as a
matter of fact,
was what hit the North American ice cap
12,800
years ago.
It looks like there was a second series
of impacts 11,600
years ago from the same source.
It looks like there were other impacts
in the bronze age.
The most recent,
almost definite impact out of the Taurid
meteor stream was Tunguska in Siberia
back in 1,908
that hit on the 30th of June 1,908
and that's at the peak of the torrid
June shower.
When we pass through the Tory,
it's in June and in November.
And what they're saying is we really
need to focus on this story of meteor
stream.
Their calculations are that there are
hundreds and hundreds of massive objects
in that Taurid meteor stream and you as
a comet breaks up into bits.
It becomes those bits become asteroids
and those asteroids are circling in the
Taurid meteor stream.
And I've likened it to strapping on a
blindfold and crossing an eight lane
interstate twice a year and just hoping
that we don't hit any heavy traffic,
you know,
that we meet bicycles or motorcycles
rather than rather than trucks.
But the trucks are out there.
And what the common research group
scientists are saying is we need now to
be in depth investigating the Taurid
meteor stream because it appears to be
the hidden hand in human civilization.
It is wiped out episodes of our history
in the past and there's no reason to
expect that it won't do so again unless
we do something about it because the
remnants of that original giant comment
are still circling in the Tory of media
stream and they are fucking dangerous.
Now,
how is this being received in mainstream
science?
I mean is there any resistance to this
because it seems like this is all pretty
straightforward and in traceable Mosley
being ignored,
mostly being ignored.
I think that is why scientists who have
a vested interest in other ideas,
first of all,
there's a vested interest in not
admitting that cataclysms are important
at all.
This goes right back to really to the
19th century when science began to take
shape in the form that we know it now
and they wanted to separate themselves
off understandably from superstition.
So they didn't want anything to do with
something that sounds like the biblical
flood,
for example.
They felt they would be contaminated by
that and they preferred to explain any
cataclysmic evidence as a result of
gradual processes.
So you really think it's because of the
reluctance to accept religion or
religious ideas or to to separate
themselves.
I think that was the,
that's where it starts,
where it started to separate them
ourselves off from that.
Now they've gone a long way from that.
And many,
many scientists have got a vested
interest in what is called
uniformitarianism more gradualism and
they,
they don't like to hear about cataclysms
having any major impact on the story of
life on earth.
So is it sort of the,
the momentum of these initial,
uh,
desires to escape religious influence
that have sort of led them down this
path?
Yes.
And then there are others who have a
vested interest in current accounts of
global warming and there's others who
have a vested interest in extinctions
taking place.
Now they want to say that our ancestors
were responsible for the extinction of
all the mammoths and mastodons and so on
and so forth.
Whereas the comment research group
scientists are saying no,
those huge mega fauna of North America
were wiped out as a result of the
massive series of impacts on the North
American ice cap.
I'm reading a book right now by Dan
Flores.
Really interesting book called Coyote
America.
He's a wildlife historian and he,
uh,
is really an expert on all the different
forms of wildlife in North America where
they originated,
where they migrated to.
And one of the more fascinating things
about it is he's talking about all these
animals that went extinct,
you know,
10,000
plus years ago,
this mass extinction event and never
once does he bring up cataclysms.
And there's all these different,
uh,
is different ideas.
And one of the big ones being that human
beings with Adam [inaudible],
which is like really a very weird
sort of a spear throwing device and
wiped out the wooly mammoths and all
these other animals and Tummy tuck
posture,
lunatic idea.
I'll see if you have any contact with
hunter gatherer as today.
You find that a hunter gatherer peoples
don't overkill that game.
They,
they hunt them respectfully,
they take what they need and they leave
the rest because it's a renewable
resource for them.
So I don't think hunter gatherers wiped
out the mammoths in North America.
The evidence is compelling.
It was the comment,
well,
the evidence that you brought up when
you were here the first time,
when you showed the images of all those
mammoths that had been literally knocked
over with broken legs from the impact of
something mass burial grounds,
like these mass,
not burial grounds obviously,
but mass casualties mortality.
So it's a good way of putting it.
That's a good way of putting it.
Yeah.
In fact,
grandma,
I visited one up in South Dakota called
hot springs where there's just several
dozen,
nobody knows how many are actually
there,
but there's at least several dozen,
uh,
two species,
woolly mammoths and Columbian mammoths
that have been in tuned.
And,
um,
while we were there,
I interestingly,
I,
you know,
the,
the guide,
the woman giving us the tour there was
kind of giving the a gradualist
explanation.
Well,
over long periods of time,
these mammoths wandered into a sinkhole
and we're too dumb to get out.
And so they became in tuned and I asked
the question,
well,
what studies have been done on the
sedimentary matrix in which their
remains are being found?
Um,
because as I'm looking at this
sedimentary matrix,
I'm seeing a massive deposit.
In other words,
a deposit that was instantaneous,
instantaneous.
And when I brought that up,
she actually got very irritated and
Miley,
they all got dismissed.
My question didn't,
um,
you know what,
we've got it all worked out.
You know,
we,
we know about that.
Well,
what is it?
we've got it all worked out and then
immediately went on with her,
but yet I had an article that was
actually written by one of the original
scientists or worked under site,
and he,
he,
his description was,
well,
it could have been that,
but also as an alternative.
And he used the term bloat and float
that what you had was wooly mammoths
that had been caught in a flood,
drowned,
and they're bloated carcasses floated
into a depression in the landscape,
and that's where they were in tuned.
And that makes a whole lot more sense to
me then the fact that,
you know,
individually,
over several thousand years,
these in these mammoths wandered into
this sinkhole and then couldn't get out.
Um,
but you've got to bear in mind we're,
we're talking about,
you know,
at the end of the last ice age,
120 roughly species of megafauna
disappeared,
which is about equivalent to the same
number of megafauna.
Species didn't habits.
The Earth today was a short period of
time,
was something like 65% of the north
American mammals when extinct 75 per
75%.
Yep.
Very short period of time,
very short period of time,
but pretty much totally coincident with
that period called the younger dryas.
And so there's nothing what we're
capable of doing today.
Back then,
I mean,
when you look at human extinction
events,
human cause extinction events,
well,
it's very logical.
And what we're doing today with
pollution and the expanse of
civilization and weapons are a super
sophisticated.
If we wanted to,
we could wipe out a lot of different
species.
But what we're actually seeing is that
at the end of what's called the Bowling
Alley Rod,
which was the gradual warming at the end
of the last ice age that preceded the
sudden catastrophic change at 12,800,
was it the clovis culture that existed
for three to 500 years,
I think somewhere,
but they suddenly were gone.
Right,
exactly.
Simultaneous with the mammoths.
And then there are interesting studies
that are coming out now showing that at
least continental wide,
there was apparently a major human
population crash.
Exactly coincident with the Megafauna
extinctions because you had quarries
that had been mined for centuries that
are suddenly abandoned.
You have campsites that had been,
uh,
that had generations of,
of,
uh,
debris and in tool kits accumulating and
so on debris from the,
from the,
the,
the fluting of the,
the spear points and so on that are
suddenly abandoned.
Right.
So the evidence actually suggests that
the human population crashed,
which would certainly imply that they
would have been far less capable of
wiping out all of these species of
Megafaun.
Also the,
the studies of their,
their diet and their lifeways suggest
that they were very quite diverse.
They were hunter gatherers and they
focus mostly on small game.
They ate a lot of fish,
a lot of shellfish.
They gathered food.
And why would they go after the biggest,
most dangerous animal,
you know,
in the end,
the whole,
um,
and the whole array of,
of animal
and with incredible efficiency,
hunt them to extinction in a hundred
years.
It doesn't make sense.
No,
it makes no sense.
And it seems pretty silly.
It,
and especially from that time of her may
say rattled mentioned the clovis
culture.
This is for a very long time,
really until just a couple of years ago,
all of the mainstream academics in the
fields of archeology and anthropology
were saying there were no human beings
in North America before,
let's say 13,000
years ago,
give or take 500 years.
They came across the bering land bridge.
The Bering Strait at that time was above
water.
Sea level was lower.
They entered the Americas then they
weren't hit there before.
Now in the last two to three years,
there's just been a whole raft of new
scientific research and no scientist
today is prepared to defend the clovis
model anymore.
It's accepted,
of course,
that have been human beings in America
for fifty thousand sixty thousand years,
and there's weird genetic links,
like for example,
there's a trace that connects aboriginal
Australians with North Americans.
They had a common ancestor.
It's a very peculiar thing that's going
on,
and so what happens is that actually the
scientific models which constrain and
restrict research for so long do get
overthrown and that clovis model is
being overthrown
and what the missing piece of the puddle
puzzle,
I think for everybody working in this
field is the cataclysm.
The comment,
what happened between twelve thousand
eight hundred and eleven thousand six
hundred years ago,
which changed everything?
Is it be bizarre to you guys or
frustrating in any way that this is not
a mainstream idea?
This is,
this is very much fringe,
but yet it's,
it's not something that we don't have
any evidence.
Whenever,
whenever I put out a book,
I'm immediately,
there's this,
there's this huge hostile reactions.
The Michael Shermer thing,
like the Michael Shermer thing.
I mean,
I would say magicians of the gods,
which I published it in 2015 which deals
with his whole comedy issue is actually
the most thoroughly documented,
the most thoroughly referenced book that
I've ever written.
It's calm,
it's measured.
They actually don't read it.
They just say,
oh,
Hancock's brought out another book.
He's a pseudo scientists.
That's what they always call me,
or a pseudo archaeologist.
Um,
and,
and it's obviously rubbish because it
disagrees with everything that we know.
Well,
that's the point of the heretic in
society is to offer an alternative view
and,
and well documented evidence.
But it seems that we're dealing with
such a deeply ingrained mindset,
which is connected in curious ways to
power structures in our society that
it's very difficult to change it
absolutely.
In,
in,
in here.
Like Greg mentioned earlier,
there's kind of a,
it went from a religious motive I think
in the 19th century and now it's more a
political motive.
And again,
the idea that every day you'll find
something,
you know,
coming from various factions that or
we're destroying the earth and the earth
has never suffered this kind of,
you know,
assault on it before and,
and you know,
we're causing the sixth great mass
extinction and we're going to cause
catastrophic global warming if we pump
another 50 or a hundred parts per
million of carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere.
And,
and so what that has done is like many,
I won't say many,
but several of the scientists now that
have been in the forefront of
criticizing the younger dryas impact
hypothesis are also very much involved
in the global warming movement.
And the idea that we are now
precipitating the sixth grade mass
extinction having looked now at,
at mass extinctions and been really an
obsession of mine for about 30 years
now.
I've looked at everything from the
cretaceous tertiary that the Permian
Triassic,
you know,
right on down the line to the most
recent one,
which to me is really in some ways the
most interesting because the most recent
mass extinction that we're talking about
is the one that took place.
While we humans,
we're,
we're a part of the,
of the story and
between twelve thousand eight hundred
and eleven thousand six hundred years
ago,
the younger Dryas,
yes,
the younger dryas,
which is still an unexplained climate
anomaly that happened.
Um,
and I mentioned this I think in previous
broadcasts it's,
you know,
what you had was you had to spasm of,
of extreme warming followed by rapid
shifting into extreme cold,
literally within a matter of a few.
And
we're talking about um,
climate changes that are up to 15
degrees Fahrenheit within perhaps one to
five years,
which utterly dwarfs anything that we've
experienced in the last,
since the industrial revolution began.
And we still don't really understand.
And that's why this research is so
important because now we understand that
there was something cosmic that
happened.
It's left its imprint in the landscape
over what,
four continents,
five continents now of a over 50 million
square kilometers of the Earth's surface
is a Gi giant debris field of their
stuff that is only produced by massive
impacts.
These things come in at 70,000
miles an hour and you know if they have
any diameter at all,
if they're,
if they're a hundred meters or more in,
in diameter,
they are,
they are going to hit the earth really
hard.
They're not going to burn up in the
atmosphere.
And when they do,
they pack a huge amount of kinetic
energy,
a huge amount of heat and shock.
And that creates very definite chemical
products.
So nano diamonds,
so carbons,
fareol's,
so melt glass,
let's like the trinity site that was
produced in nuclear explosions.
All of these,
when they're all found together in the
same layer of soil,
and when you can put a date on that
layer of soil and when it's all over the
world,
there's only one thing can explain them,
a massive cosmic it.
I don't understand why this is
controversial.
I really don't.
I mean I do.
I understand it because I know that once
people start teaching things and once
people start doing lectures and giving
speeches,
they want to stick to their guns and
they want to,
they want to somehow or another avoid
anything that's going to contradict what
what they've been espousing.
It's gay.
This is a game changer.
This information,
it changes everything.
It changes the way we've looked at our
past.
It changes the whole story of archeology
and it changes the way we're going to
look at the future.
I think that people in academia are
reluctant to embrace that change and
they're afraid of being called pseudo
scientists because there's a whole lobby
of skeptics who use this word pseudo
scientist or a pseudo archeologist as an
instant dismissal of other ideas and
those who are in the profession,
they don't want to get tarred with that
brush.
They want to keep themselves clean and
can understand that.
But you're talking about hard evidence.
Yeah.
You're talking about this nuclear glass.
You're talking about nano diamonds.
You're talking about core samples that
show this massive shift when you do the
ice core samples,
massive shift in temperature,
and you're talking about a very clear
evidence of impacts that we know exist.
It's not like a calm,
it's a theory.
It's not like it's big foot or something
like,
you know,
like what we're looking for.
The final piece of evidence that shows
that comma is a real thing.
Exactly.
It's real.
It's totally,
it's totally,
it's totally real.
But it's so difficult for those who are
invested in other models to accept and
unfortunately they have the ear of the
media.
It's the,
it's uh,
there are all,
by the way,
all the scientists in the comic comic
research group are absolutely mainstream
scientists and they have taken a lot of
flack from their colleagues for even
daring to investigate this area.
Why they've had no
funding.
They've had to fund themselves.
That is so crazy because this is not a
controversial thing in my mind.
It shouldn't be.
It should not be.
This is not an airy fairy thing.
We're not talking about psychics.
We're not talking about Ufos.
Were were talking about something we
know exists,
so to bury your head in the sand over
something like this seems to me vested
interests tested interest right now.
Now say spending the equivalent of a one
attack helicopter a year on
investigating the comets and asteroids
danger,
you know,
$50 million a year.
That's not that much.
It's peanuts.
It's a tiny,
it's a minuscule,
some hundreds of billions of dollars on
on massive sophisticated military
equipment,
which we can use to slaughter one
another in evermore sophisticated ways,
but just $50 million a year on saving
the earth from,
from a potential cataclysm that could
put our civilization back into the stone
age tomorrow.
And I don't mean to keep harping on
Michael Shermer because I liked Michael,
but he,
he highlights this sort of natural
inclination to poke fun at something
that he has done no research on
whatsoever.
When I pointed out,
go back Lee Tappi and I sent him some
articles from national geographic,
he went radio silent.
I mean cause just like he should know
about it.
It's astonishing.
The number of people will mocking it.
Yeah,
you're going to mock it.
You should actually know what you're
mocking.
And to say that,
go back to the tempe was created by Hud
together as well.
I'm sorry.
That's just a theory.
That's not it.
That's not a fact that you have a
sophisticated site with astronomical
alignments with hundreds and hundreds of
megalithic pillars weighing up to 20
tons each.
The world's first perfectly aligned
north south building,
which you can only do with astronomy.
This is,
it's not enough to say,
oh,
they were just hunter gatherer is there
was something as strong from a half a
mile away.
Yeah.
I mean there's,
there's some serious sophistication.
I mean,
what,
how big were these stones?
Well,
the,
the biggest one actually still in the
quarry,
they left it because it had a fault in
it.
They clearly intended to move it 50
tons.
You're looking at 20 foot high objects
and they,
and then it's the,
it's the putting together of them.
See,
here's the problem.
Hunter gatherer societies are not the
kinds of societies that produce large
scale fixed monuments.
Why?
Because they don't generate a surplus.
You can't pay for somebody to become an
architect and four of those times
somebody to come and astronomy,
you'd busy hunting and gathering and
that's what you do.
Agriculture generates a surplus and
that's the,
that is the problem at Gabelli Tapi
because there is no background.
This site just appears out of nowhere,
a midst what appears to be a hunter,
gather a community.
But what they're not considering is the
possibility.
We're looking at a technology transfer
that the survivors of a lost
civilization who already had all that
knowledge came to go back,
Lee Tepi and use that site as a center
of initiation to teach the local hunter
gatherer is how to do agriculture and
that's now taken as the beginnings of
civilization.
I would say it is the reinvention or the
re making of civilization.
So when we're looking at Summa,
there are any artifacts we find ancient
Mesopotamia and that area of Iraq.
Those are the people that are sort of
reinventing and relearning.
Well that that's hence all those.
They,
when we talk of Mesopotamia,
which means between two rivers,
the Tigris and the Euphrates go Beckley.
Tempe is sitting right there in the
headwaters between the Tigris and
Euphrates.
And we cannot separate that from the
later cultures that enter history five
thousand six thousand years ago.
They're part of the lineage that
descended from Gore Beckley,
Tempe Times.
And what's fascinating about Gabelli
Tempe is the way it doesn't fit the way.
There's no background to it that you
would expect to see them practicing
learning architectural skills.
The oldest stuff should be the worst.
And as they carry on,
it gets better.
That site ran for a thousand years.
The best stuff is the oldest.
A thousand years later,
what they were producing wasn't so good.
This is a real anomaly and it needs to
be investigated,
not mocked by skeptics,
but actually explore to consider maybe
this does rock the whole paradigm.
And it's kind of ironic
that in their desire to get away from
the ancient myths and tales in the
Bible,
they've ignored those ancient myths and
tales,
which all talk about cataclysms.
Well,
part of our modern psychology is to
imagine that we are somehow so far
advanced from our predecessors that we
now represent the pinnacle of
civilization.
And anything to proceeded us has to be
looked upon almost is as if the,
the workings of children.
It requires a major psychological shift
to admit or accept that our ancestors
who may have been far,
far more sophisticated than,
than we had imagined in our 19th century
models,
which basically still dominate thinking
today.
And,
um,
you know,
in Graham's book he devotes several
chapters to the story of one 19th or
20th century heretic.
J Harlan Brett's in his story to me,
kind of encapsulates the whole,
the whole process of forcing this
paradigm shift.
And for years he was out there exploring
this evidence that there had been this
tremendous flooding in,
uh,
in,
in Washington state.
And all of his critics were dismissive
without ever even going out and looking
at the evidence firsthand in the field.
But what he did was he stuck to his guns
for three decades and continued to amass
evidence to the point where they just
couldn't,
they couldn't dismiss it anymore.
And finally,
um,
a group of them went out,
and began to explore the,
the,
the landscapes for themselves in one of
the leaders.
I think you talked about it in your
book,
James Gillooly,
who was sort of the leader of the
skeptic faction that had set out their
sole purpose was to discredit and lay
this whole flood heresy to rest once and
for all.
But he went out into field and they
spent about eight days in the field
where he's seeing this evidence for
himself over and over again.
And when you're looking at just one
piece of it,
you might be able to say,
okay,
there's all other explanations for that.
But what happens is when you get
multiple lines of evidence all
converging,
and there's no way to individually
explain a way each one of those things,
other than just saying,
oh,
well it's all coincidence.
He,
this James Gillooly was honest enough so
that after a week out there,
they were at a place called palouse
falls in southern Washington,
which was one of these areas where these
tremendous inland tsunami swept across
the land.
Um,
and I actually just visited there about
eight weeks ago when I took a group of
people out there and,
and,
and took them to palouse falls to show
them right on the spot where James
Gillooly was standing when he finally
had his epiphany.
Do you have any images of that that you
brought with us?
I have images.
I can dig them up here.
Yeah,
I sure do.
Yeah.
I've got some really interesting images
to show you.
Um,
which relates because see this flooding
stuff relates directly to the idea of
the impact and we can get into a little
bit of that,
um,
explaining how,
how these parallel lines of,
of evidence are now converging.
But the interesting thing about,
but Gillooly was that in the,
in the,
uh,
descriptions of,
of the trip,
he wandered off by himself for a long
time away from the group.
And we're standing here looking at this
massive cataract with 400 foot cliffs in
this little tiny ribbon of water flowing
over it in this huge canyon below it and
these big boulders.
And he'd seen for a whole week he'd been
seeing this stuff.
And it finally got to the point where it
was undeniable and he walked back to the
group and the words out of his mouth
verbatim where,
how could I have been so wrong?
And he finally admitted.
And at that that was like a turning
point.
And now,
and again,
Graham describes it's very effectively
in the book how in a,
in a way the flooding phenomena was
hijacked and then placed within this
more gradual listic context,
um,
to,
to really to avoid the fact that it was
something so anomalous in,
so such a departure from our modern
experience that we had to look outside
of our modern experience to find an
explanation.
What they wanted to do was find
something within our modern experience.
And this is the cornerstone of the
uniformitarian a approach is that we
look for a modern example and then we
extrapolate backwards from that.
And so what they did was they saw,
well in,
in the modern term,
in the modern world,
we have pro glacial lakes lake,
that's that form in front of glaciers.
And sometimes these pro glacial lakes
might be held in by uh,
an ice dam or another glacier.
These ice dams will give away and they
will cause pretty catastrophic flooding.
They're very common up in Iceland
because you've got several volcanoes
under the Wioa,
the Icelandic ice sheets.
And up there they use the term Yoga
Lopes to describe these outburst floods.
But here's the thing,
when you look at the modern versions of
it,
you basically are looking at floods that
are less than 1000th of one single flow
from these floods we're talking about.
That happened,
you know,
12 and 13,000
years ago,
1000 less than a thousandth less than a
thousand then peak discharge and in
total volume.
And,
and so in his been admitted in several
places,
I've extracted the quotes saying,
well,
we do admit that this is a major
extrapolation upwards,
but nevermind.
Yeah,
you know,
her
mind is so disturbing me.
See Holland breaths for for 30 years was
walking the walk and the channel scab
lands.
And what he saw was evidence for,
um,
as he called it,
a humongous flood,
which,
which actually rosen fall within fell
within three weeks.
And,
and he went through decades of being put
aside by his colleagues in salted.
They mocked him,
they laughed at him just as the skeptics
do today.
But gradually the evidence began to Matt
and they couldn't deny it anymore that
there had been,
there had been flooding.
And actually eventually they gave Harlan
Brett's j Harlan,
Brett's the penrose metal,
which is the ultimate,
you know,
uh,
the ultimate bestowal of,
of geology in America.
He got the accolade and he said it,
that he was born more than 90 years old
at that time.
And he said at that time,
he said,
all my enemies are dead,
so I have no one left a gloat over.
Um,
but,
but the point is,
in a way,
there was nothing to gloat about because
what they did was they,
they,
they separated him from his central
idea.
Instead of accepting that there had been
one huge flood.
And that was always his view.
They said,
oh,
there must have been 70 or 80 floods
that caused all this damage.
And that's what we're,
that's what we are seriously challenging
right now.
It's so ironic in a way that the human
desire for knowledge is what has led us
to where we are today.
We have this insatiable desire for
knowledge and for innovation,
but that same human desire to achieve is
also what,
what's the,
is responsible for that and the ego
blocks anything that's contrary to what
you've already established as fact.
Exactly.
As soon as you see something that might
throw a monkey wrench into the gears of
what you've been teaching and practicing
your whole life.
And I know that you've gone through this
with Egypt,
you're your whole issue with the Sphinx
and with a doctor shock.
And John Anthony West who was on the
podcast last one was with you just
recently.
Yeah,
he's amazing.
By the way,
I'm going to be doing,
uh,
an event in New York with John Anthony
West and on the 29th of November where,
uh,
it's,
well,
again,
it's linked on my website.
The details are on the talks and events
page.
It's in,
it's in some church somewhere,
but I'm going to give a presentation and
then I'm going to interview John Live on
live on stage.
First Time I've ever done that.
I'm kind of,
podcasting is such a character.
He's an amazing dude and um,
magical Egypt is,
I think one of the most important things
that anybody could ever watch.
I think that DVD series is just insane.
It's so spectacular and so fantastic.
And next to going to Egypt without,
which I haven't done.
I think that's probably the second best
thing.
Just bet you bet.
And John
is an example of why we need heretics.
This is,
this is the thing,
you see that,
that the science today,
yes,
you're right.
We have this thirst for knowledge and
it's k human characteristic,
but also we get invested in particular
positions and when people criticize
those positions,
we take it as an existential threat and
where we get all angry and hot and
bothered about it.
If we allow that to happen too much,
we don't keep a place for heretics in
our society,
then we're never going to do anything
novel.
We are gradually going to get locked
down ossified into the,
into the existing system we need
heretics.
John has been the leading heretic on
ancient Egypt for decades.
Pointing out that we should listen to
what the ancient Egyptians said,
that their civilization was not a
development,
it was a legacy.
It was a legacy from the time of the
gods and that cost me back again to this
whole issue of a lost civilization.
Now when God Bagley,
tabby was discovered,
it vindicated you in so many ways,
but what are the possibilities,
if any,
of more of these sites being explored
and exposed?
A few.
Are there,
are there more that people are looking
at right now?
Are there any that are under the radar?
Just a year ago at the bottom of the
Sicily channel at a depth of more than
120 feet.
It's been underwater for at least 9,000
years is a huge megalithic sites.
Before the discovery of go Beckley Tepi,
that site could never have been
explained.
The dating is absolutely definite.
The seas rose and covered it at least
9,000
years ago.
We don't know how long it stood there
before it was covered by the rising
seas.
But there it sits under water.
And I think underwater discoveries or,
and I've had a part to play in this over
the years,
are,
are one of the ways forward.
We need to look at those areas because
there was a 400 foot rise in sea level.
At the end of the ice age.
You're looking at the amount of land
that would be put together in,
say,
Europe and China added together.
That amount of land was swallowed by
those rising seas.
And archeology has largely proceeded
without taking account of those lost
lands.
I'm not saying they haven't looked at
all,
but they're primarily in marine
archeology interested in shipwrecks.
Now this,
uh,
this megalithic site is their images of
this that we could look at.
There are,
yeah.
Yeah.
I can,
I can probably find it,
um,
a monolith at the bottom of the Sicily
channel.
Try that.
A search on that.
Pull that up,
Jamie.
But,
um,
so what does this look like?
Is this,
and this has been clearly established
that this actually is the work of man.
This is not some sort of a Yardang or
something.
Of course there's dispute.
Of course,
the mainstream is not going to just
accept this overnight,
but again,
it's mainstream scientists are funded.
They're absolutely certain that they're
dealing with a manmade site.
There are holes drilled through these
megaliths.
Uh,
one of them is very,
very large.
There's a series of other megaliths
round about,
it's not a natural thing.
So here we're looking at some of her,
right?
Yeah.
So there's that big,
big megalith broken into two parts right
there.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and this,
we can say often with archeological
sites,
the problem is dating them.
You know,
for example,
there are incredible megalithic temples
all over the island of Malta,
not far away from this place.
Incredible megalithic temples,
but they can't date the stone directly.
They have to date organic material
associated with the stone and that can
give them misleadingly young dates.
In a case of a site that's been covered
by sea level rise,
there can be no argument.
Nobody went down there and built that
9,000
years ago.
It had to be built before the seas rose
and that puts a minimum age on it of
9,000
years.
What are the best images that we can
look at it?
Cause right now I'm just seeing rocks.
It's very difficult cause I'm looking at
something that I mentioned and I'm
afraid that's all you're going to see.
Those are,
those are the best images of it that
exists over one right above that.
That's Indiana Goonie.
That's that.
That's not in,
that's not in the Sicily channel.
So,
um,
what,
what are the biggest pieces down there?
Is it this right here?
Is this what yeah,
that big thing.
Big thing there is 30 feet long I think.
And is it,
what,
what leads you to believe that this is
manmade?
The scientists who worked on it,
the fact that there are holes drilled
through the stone,
the fact that you can go to neighboring
areas like Armenia and find Brealey,
very ancient megalithic sites where they
have exactly the same kind of holes
drilled through the stones and the whole
seem to have been used for astronomical
sightings.
Now this sites a mass,
it's been knocked over by the sea.
It's fallen down,
but we're seeing the same thing.
Big megaliths with holes drilled through
them.
And you're also dealing with 9,000
plus years of erosion and barnacle grows
all of that.
And the ocean is a difficult place to
work.
You know,
it's,
it's a,
it does,
it's not easy.
Visibility can be bad.
You're dealing with currents.
There's all kinds of,
all kinds of problems because this is
the important just cubs,
cameron and his crazy little summary in
ringing James Cameron.
Well I spent seven years scuba diving
all around the world looking at this
stuff.
And you know,
it's pretty convincing in my view.
Well
it is.
It does make sense that if we do know
for a fact and we do that the sea level
rose dramatically at the end of the ice
age,
it makes sense that some things would be
buried under the water.
Well in,
during the Ice Age,
whatever,
you know,
you don't have to talk about advanced
civilizations or anything,
but during the ice age,
living under coastlines in establishing
your villages,
communities and everything under
coastlines would've been probably one of
the most benign places,
um,
to get,
you know,
because for one thing,
you're,
you're down,
you're see the sea level of this
presence of the c's is going to,
uh,
you know,
smooth out the climate and so forth.
So,
you know,
you're going to have mold.
Probably most cultural development
during the ice age is going to be close
to this,
to the sea.
So it's going to be underwater now,
just like grandma's was talking about.
Um,
and so this to me is probably the future
of archeology is marine archeology where
a lot of discoveries are going to be
made.
And,
and that particular thing,
I mean there's a lot of megalithic
structures around the world that if you
set that thing up like this and put
those siding holes through it,
um,
would,
would look precisely like scrape the
barnacles off of it,
you know,
and,
and no one's saying,
oh,
it's proven,
but what it is is we have to keep an
open mind and say,
well,
there are some very strong similarities
here,
so let's investigate this thing further.
And that's the whole point of all this
is all of this stuff needs more
research.
It doesn't need some cavalier dismissal
by somebody who's,
you know,
protecting their own paradigm.
It needs more research on all fronts.
I mean,
because I think that there's enough
evidence that has now accumulated to
suggest that there is a deep history to
the human species on earth and we're
just beginning to really appreciate how
much deeper it really is.
Then the conventional models of history
and rather than just waving an arm and
dismissing this,
um,
with a skeptical sneaker with a
skeptical sneer.
Exactly.
Oh,
it's interesting is that there is an
accepted scientific models of humanity
when you're talking about
supervolcanoes,
right,
like the Super Volcano of 60 70,000
years ago.
Yeah.
I mean they're,
they pretty much accept that that wiped
out of the vast majority of human beings
on earth.
And why is the super volcano hypothesis
so easily accepted?
But yet the asteroidal impact,
I mean,
both of them are real events.
Both of them are historically
documented.
In fact,
we really don't,
we've never watched a supervolcano take
over the world,
but we've seen asteroids hit other
planets.
We've actually watched shoemaker Levy,
like you were talking about before,
we call them bonding Jupiter.
Unbelievable.
Bigger impact in the planet earth
itself.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
So,
yeah,
and actually more than 20 impacts each,
each,
each one of them would have wiped out
all life on earth if that,
if that object at hit the earth.
Yeah.
So,
you know,
so it's a,
it's a,
it's another thing to when we were
talking about underwater structures,
but let's also consider the possibility,
and again,
John Anthony West work is important
here.
Let's also considered the possibility
that we have miss identified a number of
structures that are standing in plain
view like the Great Sphinx Egyptology
read any age of logical text,
any encyclopedia.
Actually they will tell you that thing
was put there by a specific pharaoh,
Pharaoh carfrae of the fourth dynasty
round about 2,500
BC.
That is not a fact that is an opinion,
but it's presented as a fact.
There is not a single inscription that
relates the Sphinx to that fair or not a
contemporary inscription,
not one dating from 2,500
BC.
Um,
in fact,
there's nothing at all.
It's just the assumption because it's
close to a pyramid which they assume the
same fair are built.
Again on the absence of evidence that
the Sphinx must have been built by them.
But John Anthony West was the first to
see that.
Actually when we look at this thing,
we we're looking at a highly eroded
stone object and that erosion is very
odd and that's why he brought professor
Robert Schoch,
professor of geology from Boston
University to Giza in 1992 to look at
the Sphinx.
And say what actually caused this
weathering on the Sphinx and shock
immediately saw it,
what caused it was exposure to a very
long period of heavy,
heavy,
heavy rainfall and no such rains have
fallen in Egypt in the last 5,000
years,
but they did fall during the younger
dryas.
We had a prolonged rain out from this
comet impact.
As that ice cap was pulverized and a
massive amount of ice water was thrown
up into the upper atmosphere,
prolonged grainer,
which could have been the cause of the
erosion on the Sphinx.
Now,
what has occurred,
knew what discoveries have been
discovered in the last year.
Like what,
what is new that we can look at the,
in terms of archeology,
there's not much new,
um,
go back.
Lee Tempe at the moment is in deep
freeze.
It's right 30 miles from the Syrian
border.
There's been massive unrest,
unrest in Shenandoah,
which is the main town archeology is
very difficult for them to carry on
their space,
basically just frozen where they just
sort of stopped.
They've just kind of stopped,
you know,
and in fact,
there's amazing number of these of these
sites.
And other sites that I visited for
magicians of the gods was Baalbek in the
Lebanon.
Absolutely stunning sight and again,
I'm convinced that that site is nuanced.
It is,
yes,
there is a rub temple there,
but they put that temple there because
the site was sacred long before and
there's this incredible u shaped
megalithic wall which surrounds Baalbek,
which does not appear to have any
connection to the,
to the Roman structure at at,
at all.
Again,
that's an area which is subject to
tremendous unrest and difficult and it's
difficult for archaeologists to proceed,
but just just in 2014 they,
they made a huge new discovery at
Baalbek cover buried block,
which weighs 1,460
tons which was sitting there on the
site.
They've been working on that site for
100 years.
They only found it in 2014 1000 tons.
What?
1,460
times that 2 million pounds.
Is that what that is?
I don't know.
Maybe it was math is better than mine
and converting it into power
2000 pounds,
2000 pounds to a,
to a turn to an imperial ton,
so whatever,
and add three zeros on it,
doubled it and add three zeros on it.
It's a horrendous amount of pounds,
put it that way.
It's the single largest block of stone
ever cut and it in the ancient world.
And they found this just in 2014 found
in 2014 now there's another big one
right beside it,
which has been in plain view for about
the last hundred years and it's
astonishing to me that this one,
which is just below it was covered by
sediment.
We have an actual calculator.
You might be the only person unless I
never go anywhere without my calculator.
We'll calculator.
Nobody has one of those.
We were just talking about that
yesterday.
We were like,
who the fuck is an actual guy can carry
one.
Wow.
So Baalbek was also the site of a,
I mean there,
there's many mountain model lists that
have been discovered there and it's a
really fascinating site that most many
people have sort of overlooked.
When you talk about ancient structures
in the past,
I have to resist.
I,
I've got nothing against
aliens,
but I don't need aliens to explain these
things.
Um,
I think a much,
a much leaner and more elegant
explanation for these huge archeological
anomalies is a lost human civilization
much better.
That's been the case that I've been
making for pr for 25 years.
I think that the alien thing is a bit of
a distraction for,
of course there's aliens.
Of course the universe is full of life,
but the ancient archeological sites are
not good evidence for that idea that
they're very,
unless you massage the evidence a lot,
they're not good evidence.
I think we are dealing with a lost human
civilization and at Baalbek 20 feet
above the ground,
we have three blocks of stone joined so
closely together that you can't get it
edge of a sheet of paper between them.
Each one weighs more than 900 tons and
they are 20 feet above the ground.
The stunning,
it's a stunning achievement.
It's just absolutely astonishing.
How on earth did they do that?
How does mainstream archeology deal with
that?
They say are the Romans built it all?
Oh the Romans.
The Romans did it.
The Romans did do some awesome stuff.
They did do some awesome stuff.
They absolutely did.
But this site is separate from the Roman
site.
Its surrounds it,
but it's not part of it in my view.
In terms of your question,
what's happened within the last year or
two,
I would think that probably the most
significant thing or certainly right up
there would be the the the comic
research and the discovery.
I mean like this article I have right
here,
which came out in 2014 so it's not that
old.
A Nano diamond rich layer across three
continents consistent with major cosmic
impact at 12,800
years ago and it's something like 24 25
highly pedigreed science
and these are the comic research group.
These are the scientists from the call
research group who have funded all their
research themselves.
They came out with another paper in 2015
where was this published?
If anybody wants to read this?
That's in the general of Glg.
Yeah,
but then there's the proceedings of the
National Academy of Sciences host a lot
of their work as well,
and the proceedings of the National
Academy of Sciences get into trouble for
hosting their work,
but they feel it's important so they
keep on hosting it.
This is so spectacularly confusing to me
because that's rock solid science.
This is evidence.
This is actually,
you can weigh this stuff.
You can measure it.
You can,
you can run tests on it and find out
what its components are.
This to me is so baffling.
Yeah,
it's very baffling.
They brought out another paper in 2015 I
won't go into the some of the details
that boring,
but it's called a Basey and
chronological analysis.
And basically what they're,
what they were looking at is it,
they ask themselves,
is it possible that this evidence,
these nano diamonds,
these melt glass,
that carbon's failures could that have
been laid down gradually and the
chronological analysis that they've done
absolutely answers that.
No,
it was not laid down gradually.
This whole thing unfolded in a period of
about 24 hours.
Whoa.
One at night.
Yeah.
And what had happened,
Joe,
was that for years archeologists had
recognized this a black matte layer at,
at about two dozen or more of the clovis
sites around North America,
which there had been over 50 of them
that have been studied.
And it would see Vance Haynes who wrote
an interesting paper saying that,
um,
that he was the one who noted that below
this black matte layer,
which is only two to three inches thick
in most sites,
you found evidence of the clovis
culture.
You found their tool kits in their,
their,
um,
spear points.
And so on.
You found evidence of the extinct
megafauna,
but not above it.
You would find this evidence of this
cultural activity and the megafauna
right up to the bottom of the,
of the,
um,
black matte layer,
but not above it.
So what finally happened was in 2007,
um,
Richard firestone and Allen West and
some of their colleagues,
and it was just basically a small group
at that point,
took a look at this closer look,
and that's when they began to discover
these impact proxies,
usually right at the base of the layer.
And the layer itself is carbonaceous,
which suggests that there had been a lot
of sick deposited,
which would imply widespread wildfires
factors.
A study off the right off the coast of
California here on the Santa Rosa Island
is it pretty much concluded that there
was just massive wildfires.
It pretty much just in Ila,
did everything.
And in this was proceeded by the
deposition of this black matte layer.
And right at the bottom of this black
matte layers where you find the nano
diamonds,
the magnetic grains,
the microspheres roles,
um,
the carbonaceous spherials.
Um,
fullerenes you,
you find these impact proxies and then
are not all the same at all the sites.
In fact,
that's been one of the things that the
critics of seized upon,
but what they're doing is I think taking
an oversimplified model and when you
look at a comic fragmentation event,
you could be looking at the individual
pieces could be have very different
compositions and what we were talking
about earlier,
the Taurid meteor stream.
I'm not convinced at this point that it
was necessarily just a single impact
event.
It may have been a bombardment episode
that may have lasted even several
decades.
It may have been ceased for a while and
we were talking about this last night
over dinner that there seems to be a
second spasm at 11,600
years ago.
That's also associated with a massive
rise in sea level.
They call a,
there's two meltwater spikes,
meltwater spike one a and meltwater
spike one B.
I'm quite convinced that these meltwater
spikes that have been documented by
marine geologists and oceanographers are
correlated with these melting events of
the ice sheet that I've been looking at
in terms of their,
their geomorphic,
uh,
um,
consequences because some of these
events,
I mean,
the only way I can describe some of
these meltwater advances that the only
modern analog to this would be a
tsunami.
And we've seen some pretty devastating
tsunamis within the last decade or two.
Um,
both in Indonesia and in Japan.
And I don't know if you've ever seen any
of that,
like the videos of these tsunamis,
anybody listening,
it is definitely worthwhile to go online
and look at some of these videos where
you can actually see the,
the unbelievably powerful effects of a,
of a 30 or 40 or 50 foot tsunami right
now,
some of the landscapes,
and I have a,
um,
some images we can pull up here shortly.
Um,
our places in Montana,
Idaho,
Washington where you literally had as
tsunami sweeping over the land there was
over a thousand feet deep and that
tsunami came off the ice cap.
And that that's not an oceanic tsunami.
It's a freshwater tsunami.
It's meltwater coming off this,
this catastrophic melting of the ice
sheet and I've traced the sources of
some of these meltwater.
I've made two trips now up into the end
of the plateau country of British
Columbia looking for the source of this
meltwater because in the conventional
models now of the this flooding this
that goes back to Harlan Brett's and
basically what they've done is they said
initially there could have been no flood
because Harlan Brett's didn't provide a
source for the water.
They said,
the critics said,
well,
you're saying that all of this evidence
in the landscape is evidence of the
flood,
but what was the source of the flood?
And he didn't have a source.
So the crane and said,
well,
you don't have a source for the
floodwater.
Therefore the flood didn't take place.
Then as,
as the research evolved,
you had independent evidence
accumulating in western Montana by jt
Pardee,
who was with the US Geological Survey
and he was investigating evidence that
the mountain valleys of western Montana
had been filled up with an enormous
volume of water.
And this volume of water seemed to be
exactly the same time as Brett's is
floods.
He then assumed that this was a giant
lake.
And because you can see in,
and we can,
I think we have some images,
I think Jamie has some images,
so we'll pull them up shortly.
We're on a mountain side,
you see to shorelines etched,
you know,
a thousand feet above the valley floor.
And what he then decided was that based
upon an old 19th century,
uh,
interpretation by TC chamberlain that
there had been an ice dam.
He said,
well,
there must have been an ice dam west of
here somewhere in the Clark Fork Valley.
A giant lake backed up,
burst through the ice dam.
And then this is what would have caused
Harlan.
Brett's is floods.
So now the geological community is
shifting because number one,
the evidence is overwhelming and they
can't deny it anymore.
But what they're doing is looking for a
gradualist or a more uniformitarian
explanation.
So they immediately latched on to this.
Well,
there was a giant pro glacial or in
front of a glacial lake,
uh,
in western Montana.
Well,
you're talking about somewhere between
520 and 550 cubic miles of water.
That's a of water right in,
in,
in a,
normally when you have a large lake,
you have a huge catchment base and it is
feeding lots of streams and rivers that
are feeding into that lake.
When you look at the,
any of the big lakes around North
America,
you have the lake and then you have this
big ole catchment basin and all of
that's feeding in Lake Missoula.
The whole lake fills almost the whole
catchment basin.
It's like,
to me what they did was they said,
okay,
we're just going to push the source of
the water from here over to here,
but let's not go into the question of
where did the water come from?
That's filling these mountain valleys of
western Montana.
And this is what I had.
I spent a couple of weeks in September
going up into some of these,
following these valleys up into British
Columbia.
And they're spectacular evidence.
And it's almost like the American
geologists stop at the,
at the 49th parallel,
and they say,
well,
that's the Canadians,
uh,
preserve up there.
We'll let them there.
They've got their own theories.
We've got ours.
Interestingly,
the Canadians are saying that we think
that the water for these floods came
from up here,
but they don't like that because you see
one of the leading geologists who,
who,
who's saying that these floods came from
from Canada is John Shaw,
who,
who basically came up.
There was this idea that drum Lynn's,
which are these inverted bolt hole
shaped land forms,
they're found by hundreds of thousands,
uh,
in regions where,
where glaciers were that they were
formed,
not by the glaciers grinding over the
landscape,
but they were actually formed by massive
subglacial flows of water.
And his critics have all been saying,
well,
here's the problem.
What's the source of your water?
Therefore,
it wasn't water,
wasn't subglacial floods.
It's easy parallels that Harlan.
Brett's his story very closely.
Well,
here's the thing,
Sean,
his colleagues couldn't really come up
with a plausible explanation for how you
could form these massive subglacial
reservoirs.
In fact,
what they call the living stone lake
event required 84,000
cubic kilometers of water and I 84,000
kilometers.
I can do it really quickly here.
We would divide that by 30 36 that's
about 2,300
cubic miles of water.
That's more than all of the Great Lakes
combined,
vastly bigger than all of the Great
Lakes combined.
It's probably every lake in North
America combined,
and he said,
this one event required over 2000 cubic
miles of water.
Well,
where did that water come from?
So he basically said,
well,
there must have been a reservoir.
Somehow that formed his critics have
said,
that's impossible.
You couldn't form that much water under
the ice sheet.
Well,
what's happened now is the idea of a
major cosmic impact into the ice sheet
has completely obviated the need for a
subglacial reservoir.
Because now we have a way of
instantaneously
melting enormous volumes of,
it's no longer a mystery where the water
came from.
It's fully explained,
and this has been the missing piece of
the puzzle until the [inaudible]
research group began to identify this
evidence
baffling to me that this is a source of
controversy because we know that the
great lakes were created by melting
glaciers.
We also know that there's vast areas of
North America that are flattened by
these glaciers.
You know,
a buddy of mine,
my friend Doug,
lives in Cazenovia,
Wisconsin,
which is what's called the driftless
area,
where the,
the glaciers didn't go through.
I just was there,
uh,
in May.
It's beautiful.
It's gorgeous gifts,
rolling hills,
and it's just,
it wasn't,
it wasn't crushed flat like other parts
of North America war.
Right?
So we know,
we know that those glaciers melted and
they created the Great Lakes.
I mean,
the Great Lakes were from glaciers.
We know that that's an established fact.
So why has all this confusing?
I just don't understand why they
wouldn't just add that to it.
They just couldn't accept the great,
the glaciers.
Somehow or another in the last 10,000
years,
the glaciers just decided to stop
smashing North America flat and melt and
create these great inland oceans of
French water.
Yeah,
yeah.
Bizarre.
It's,
it's very bizarre.
Ultimately a lot,
a lot of ideology is,
is involved in this.
There's,
there's um,
there's this design.
I also have been cut in the modern world
as a design not to panic.
The public,
not to say things that are,
that are going to cause that are going
to cause panic.
You know,
Donald Trump being president.
I think people are ready now.
I think people are ready for panic.
I think so.
Is there,
is anybody debated you on this,
either one of you on this?
Well,
you know,
I tried to them but not specifically on
this.
I tried to do a debate with Zahi Hawass
who was the guy who runs the Giza
pyramids.
And then total total,
I mean,
very crazy event.
There's a video of it online.
Quite a a video of it online.
Did they last what,
30 seconds?
It's something like something like that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And then,
and then later on when he,
when he finally agreed to come back into
the room,
cause he was so angry with me,
walked out,
when he finally came back into the room,
he was asked a question about it.
Go back to the tippy and just like
you're skeptic,
he didn't know anything about go back to
the technique or he claimed not to know
about it.
I mean this is the,
this is supposed to be the world's most
famous archaea Egyptologist and he knew
nothing about this incredible sight in
a,
in a neighboring country.
But one point to make the Randall was
talking about the second event 11,600
years ago.
We're dealing with an with,
with an episode of Cataclysm,
which begins 12,800
years ago,
an ends 11,600
both episodes accompanied by massive
floods and the 11,600
years ago data,
I may have mentioned this last year,
it's in,
it's in magicians of the gods.
What's interesting about that is that is
the exact date that plato gives us for
the destruction of the lost civilization
of Atlantis.
Plato.
That's the only source we have for
Atlantis.
It comes to us.
Many people think it's all over the
place,
but it's not.
Atlantis comes to us from the Greek
philosopher Plato,
who lived around 340 BC and he got the
story from through his family line from
his ancestors so long who had visited
Egypt in 600 BC and they're sold on,
was told of a great civilization that
had existed on earth.
That was the progenitor civilization of
Egypt.
But that was destroyed in a terrible
cataclysm.
And he asked at a cataclysm involving a
gigantic flood and Atlantis was
submerged beneath the waves and was
never seen again.
And so solid said to the priest,
when did this happen?
And they said three to 9,000
years ago,
that was in 600 BC.
So that's 9,600
BC,
that's 11,600
years ago.
That's meltwater pulse.
One B.
How could they know?
You know,
how could we have to start taking this
stuff more seriously instead of sneering
attitude and skepta sizing it out of
existence?
We need to leave a little bit of room
for extraordinary ideas possibly being
right.
That's the main beef I have with the
skeptics is that they want to throw the
baby out with the bath water.
Okay,
I want to add something to that.
In,
in the tomatoes,
you know,
Plato Discusses Atlantis in two
dialogues and into tomatoes.
He prefaces the story of Atlantis by
recounting the myth of fate.
Now the myth of Fayton is a very
interesting story.
And basically what it is,
is Fayton was the offspring of Haley
owes the sun.
God who was raised didn't know who his
father was.
His mother kept it a secret from him.
And then one day he was being taunted at
school because all of his school mates
had,
you know,
recounting the great deeds of their
fathers and everything.
So he went home distraught and finally
his mother said,
well actually your father is the,
the big granddaddy of them all.
Haley owes the Sun God.
So Fayton decides he's going to go and
find his father and eventually does and
he goes to some celestial realm or his
father is located.
And the way it is with the,
with the,
the Greek gods they have on limited
powers except they also have certain
restrictions.
For example,
if a god makes a promise,
he,
he or she cannot go back on it,
right?
So when Haley,
Oh sees fate and his,
his lost son come,
he's sober joy,
he says,
I'm so happy to see you.
I will grant you any boone you want and
fate and says,
I want to drive the chariot to the sun.
I want to drive your chariot.
And Haley,
oh says,
well I meant anything you wanted to
accept that,
you know,
so it goes back and forth and back and
forth.
Finally Phaeton convinces his father,
let him let me do it.
His father says,
look,
you've got to hang onto those reins
tight cause those steeds are going to
pull away from you.
He gets in there at the gates of the sun
open.
It describes in the myth you can go,
you know,
you can read edith with Hamilton or
bulfinch or any of the,
the,
the great retellings of the Greek myths
and they'll describe it in there.
It goes through the signs of the Zodiac
and then all of a sudden it careens off
and heads down to earth.
And then it describes his whole litany
of catastrophes.
This setting the earth on fire.
And finally the,
uh,
Jupiter,
at,
at the,
uh,
at the beseeching of Poseidon and who's
afraid that the oceans are going to boil
away,
gets Zeus to mount his,
his,
uh,
Mount Olympus and hurl his thunderbolt,
which knocks Fayton from the sky and he
falls to Earth in,
in,
in falls into the river Eridanus which
is a metaphor for the a Milky Way and
his sisters the hell yachty's then a
weep over the death of their brother and
their tears fall to earth and caused the
great flood plato.
Then after re referencing that myth,
he then says,
now this has the form of a myth,
but what it really represents is a
declaration or a declining of the bodies
in space orbiting around the earth and
an eventual falling to earth of one of
those bodies and a conflagration of all
things triggered by the fall of that
body.
It's intriguing that he mentioned the
Zodiac because you know,
cause the Taurid meteor stream is so
cold because it appears to come at us
from the direction of the constellation
of Tourist Zodiacal constellation.
That's where those shooting stars
amongst which has some very large
objects that,
that have hit us in the past and can hit
us again in the future.
That's where they come from.
They come from that area of the sky.
It's an actual human illusion.
It appears that they're,
they're not actually coming from
tourists.
It looks like that they come from that
area of the sky.
They come from that area of the sky.
And so anybody in in ancient times who
was witnessing and according to the
Victor Club and William Napier and those
guys who are the British new
catastrophists that had been doing all
of this work for decades on the Taurid
meteor shower have concluded that,
you know,
in times past it was an extremely active
shower and would have created some
pretty darn impressive light shows,
uh,
even if it wasn't causing catastrophes
down here below.
But what they've,
what they've conjectured is that there
might be times of multiple tongue goose
go like impact bombardment when um,
you know,
there could be,
cause there could be thousands of
objects within the tarred meteor stream
on the same scale as the tin goose got
object.
And that if,
if you go and you read the accounts,
the eyewitness accounts over and over
again,
people are saying things like,
well it looked like it was being
disgorged from the sun.
It looked like it was being born out of
the sun.
Right.
It looked like a second son in the sky.
Like for a short period of time,
the son had a twin,
right?
Well,
the summertime cards are coming from
their para helion passage around the
sun.
So you like green was saying they make
an elliptical orbit out to Jupiter and
back around the sun in this stream,
right.
Earth crosses that stream twice each
year.
One time,
late June,
early July,
we crossed.
But at that point they're coming from
the direction of the sun.
So they're,
their arrival to earth is going to be
very difficult to see because they're
coming from the direction of the sun.
Right.
But that's exactly where on June 30th
the Taurid meteor would be coming from.
Um,
and then also the fact that it's the
perfect date for the peak of the,
of the shower and the,
the correct place in the sky to me is
pretty convincing evidence that it was
most likely a remnant of that towards
stream.
The other time that the earth crosses
his late October,
early November,
in fact,
we've just passed out of it,
um,
within the last week basically.
But it peaks interestingly,
coincidentally,
between like October 30th and November
4th or fifth,
so it's peaking right around Halloween
time.
In fact,
they've been called the Halloween
meteors and there's some very,
sometimes they call them the Halloween
fireworks.
Yeah.
But there's some very interesting work
done by a,
um,
a researcher background,
early 20th century named Grant
Halliburton,
who spent about 15 years researching the
connections between ancient calendars.
And he concluded,
one thing very interesting was that lot
of these ancient calendars where being
synchronized by people's observations of
the rise and fall of the pleiades,
which is the shoulder of the bowl,
the pleiades comprises,
uh,
basically part of that,
constellations all tourists.
Yeah.
The shoulder of the bull.
And what he came up with was that in his
research,
he discovered that many of these stories
that were associated with this,
like the slaying of the celestial bull,
you know,
Gilgamesh and thank do into,
and the earliest known a story,
they,
they fight the celestial bowl.
There's many counterparts and variants
of that in,
in,
in mythical stories.
Um,
and so what he then found out though was
that in many cases,
the,
that,
that our modern halloween actually goes
back thousands of years to an ancient
day of the dead that was observed all
over the earth at the same time every
year,
even in the southern hemisphere.
And it usually revolves,
revolved around a commemoration of the,
the culmination of the pleiades,
which is when the pleiades crosses the
local meridian.
Another words,
it,
it reaches the key stone of the Royal
Arch,
so to speak,
up in the sky.
So if you got an eye on Halloween now
and you face the south in the northern
hemisphere,
you will see the pleiades right at
midnight,
at midnight,
they will be,
if you think of the,
the,
the arch of the Zodiac as being,
uh,
a,
um,
like a clock.
It's right there at midnight,
at midnight.
Right?
Well,
here's the interesting link is that in
all of these myths,
what Halliburton discovered over and
over again was that the day of the dead
ultimately went back to myths about,
of the destruction of the world by a
great flood and,
or fire.
It's fascinating that it's all coming
out of the Constellation tourists too,
and it's the celestial bowl that they're
fighting in these ancient myths and all
these cultures around the world are
celebrating the day of the dead have
this exact same time.
This is amazing stuff and right now our
science is closing its eyes to this.
I think it's fair to say with the Taurid
meteor stream,
which is a very big issue in this whole
discussion that we are dealing with the
hidden hand in human history.
It's something that is going to
ultimately require us to reexplain
almost everything,
but the skeptics hate it.
They can't bear it because first of all
it involves cataclysms and secondly it
involves the possibility of losing a
whole civilization from the record.
It's really,
it's really interesting when you look at
the dates of the this cluster,
this episode of bombardment between
twelve thousand eight hundred and eleven
thousand six hundred years ago.
That's the period that just immediately
precedes what mainstream academia think
of as the very beginnings of
civilization and they've just never the,
maybe it's not even their fault,
it's this is so recent.
This science is so new that they've not
had time to adapt to it,
but if they adapt to it and take this
into account,
then suddenly what was an extraordinary
and absurd and impossible idea that
there was a lost civilization 12,000
years ago becomes a very plausible and
reasonable idea and then we start once
we can.
Once we take that on board,
then we can start opening our eyes to
archeological anomalies like the Great
Sphinx,
like Baalbek likes submerged ruins like
go Beckley tappy and begin to consider
what does all this mean?
Are we in fact a species with Amnesia?
Are we here forgetful of the truth about
ourselves?
Maybe that's why we're so fucked up,
you know,
because we just actually don't know.
We've made up a story about where we
came from and what we are.
I certainly think it plays a part.
I also think that conservative
skepticism is probably prudent when
you're dealing with most scientific,
most things that come up that people are
claiming.
I mean there's so many charlatans out
there and crazy people that are claiming
new discoveries,
but in some cases they examine these
discoveries.
Is as long as they're far enough away
from us or weird enough like this new
planet that they believe their,
they have a 90 plan sign.
Yeah,
yeah.
They're pretty sure there's something
out there.
I'd passed the Kuyper belt and they
think it's massive.
They think it's at least four times,
maybe larger than the United States or
then,
excuse me,
the world and the world and got to know
a bit of about 10,000
years and that's interesting with
comments because this huge,
massive object circulating in the outer
solar system through the Kuiper belt,
which is a source of many of the
comments that hit the earth is
destabilizing comments from safe orbits
and putting them into really dangerous
or bits that come our way that correctly
if I'm wrong,
but like what?
What is the source of all these near
Earth objects?
Is this have anything to do with Earth
One and earth to,
does it have anything to do with the
initial impact that created the moon?
Is that because we were hit by another
planet,
right during the formation of the earth,
and this is all scientifically
established.
Astro scientists or astrophysicist
rather,
and a astronomers all agree on that,
right?
There's a lot of debris.
The would would go back to that to that
time,
but comments are another story because
they're coming in from the far reaches
of outer space.
They are coming,
they're coming in from the oort cloud
and the coin just vast distances away
there.
Their voyagers,
they're kind of messages from the
distant reaches of the cosmos,
who come in in an unpredictable way
because they're all bits are
destabilized by something like planet
nine.
Isn't there something called bodes law
where you,
uh,
you can measure the mass and the orbit
of a certain planet and you can
accurately depict where the next planet
is going to be and doesn't that fall
apart somewhere between Mars and
Jupiter,
this asteroid belt?
Yeah.
Which,
which would indicate that something was
probably there.
That's why the theory of the asteroid
belt,
that it wasn't exploded planet.
Of course,
there's a lot of opposition to that
theory too.
You know,
you're right.
Skepticism really has an important role
to play.
It's,
it's very,
it's really,
it's really essential that we are
skeptical and otherwise we'd all be
found Zacharias itching and waiting for
the Annunaki to land.
Exactly what the solar houses.
December 21st,
2012 we'd all be going,
what the fuck?
Now I'm homeless four years later and I
have to say there's a skeptic called
Michael Heizer who has done really an
excellent job of,
of thoroughly,
you know,
debunking the bogus translations of
Zachariah stitching.
Is,
is such an as wrong.com
is that section is wrong.com.
It's a very useful,
it's a very useful site.
So we hated him and loved him at the
same time.
So,
so sad.
I love the idea of the aliens come down
and manipulating the monkeys and making
us to mine gold.
It's a wonderful story,
but unfortunately it's a work of science
fiction.
There's not a work of fact.
Zachariah we need,
I knew him.
He was a fascinating man.
I once drove him from stonehenge to
London.
We had,
we had many conversations.
He was a deep and serious researcher,
but I think he,
I think he got,
he got carried away with his own fat.
I also think that that fantasy became
very lucrative and it also became a
source of identity to him.
And I followed him pretty closely as
well.
I've read the 12th Planet and,
uh,
I got really into his research and this
is in my early pot smoking days when I
first started smoking pot.
So I was,
I was all in,
I was all in.
And then as I got wiser and then as I
got mine on this maybe not wiser,
I started recognizing objectively why
these,
these things are so attractive.
The fantastical is more attractive than
the practical.
And so something else,
again,
I don't want to,
I don't want to put in down and I'm,
I'm here also to say that and did a lot
of really good work.
He was at,
he's a clever guy and he did a lot of
very,
very thorough research.
Um,
I've just lost my track actually smoking
too much.
Dope.
Where was I going?
Ah,
well we were talking about,
um,
the,
all the,
the difference between the fantastical
and the practical,
that there's this inclination to accept
things that are fun.
Yeah.
You know,
that's where I was going to say is that
when you start talking about the
Annunaki,
those from heaven to earth came these
fantastic creatures from,
thank you.
You've brought my memory in the Arrow
thing.
I remembered what I was going to say.
What's interesting in part because I
know it kind of wants could be good.
What was,
um,
what's,
what's interesting is that the level of
technology that's attributes
to the Anu Nakia bleak Nephilim,
that that level of technology is the
level of technology that we had in the
1970s when we were,
um,
you know,
Nasa was doing its stuff.
So it's NASA technology from the 1970s
that is projected out onto,
that is projected over the ground,
but it's projected out that is projected
out onto his theory of the past.
Now,
it seems to me very unlikely that the
Nefa limb or the Anunnaki would have had
for 400,000
years,
which is what he's saying,
the same technology that NASA had in the
1970s as much more likely that he's
projecting that onto the data rather
than that it's actually inherent in the
dark.
There was also some interesting ideas
that he had that turned out to be ideas
that scientists had also proposed about
preserving our atmosphere by,
by levitating or by suspending
reflective particles in our atmosphere.
And that that is something that the
Annunaki in his books we're going to use
gold for because gold has such unique
properties,
which is why they use gold to plate
things.
Cause you can take a little tiny piece
of gold.
You could play this entire table goals.
Really spectacular piece of,
uh,
I mean it's just,
there's nothing like it,
right?
Absolutely.
There's a lot of really good material in
such in,
but unfortunately the translations of
the texts,
the translations of the techs are not
translations of the text.
They misrepresent the text off.
And what he did was he took a 19th
century translation and he massaged it
so that it would fit his fit,
his argument.
And that's a pity.
So we need skeptics and they help us to
sift out the wheat from the chaff and
that.
But,
but at occasionally what the skeptics do
with this drive to,
to criticize anything that's not
mainstream.
Occasionally what they do is they let go
a really good idea which deserves
investigation in which the human species
could benefit from.
And that's my feeling is where this
amazing species,
we've developed all this science.
Why are we,
why are we so ready to let go of
wonderful ideas?
Well,
it's also fascinating to me that because
of what situation has been sort of
criticized for people now ignore the
stuff that's absolutely undeniable.
Like the actual stone tablets
themselves,
the clay tablets,
or you can see the depictions of the
solar system somehow or another,
these people from 6,000
plus years ago had a detailed map of the
solar system.
Clear idea of the soldiers was the size
in like a,
a relatively correct order.
And the planets in the right place.
Like they somehow or another knew that
Jupiter was bigger than Mars.
They knew these things in some weird way
and we don't know why.
And we don't know how.
Also the caduceus representing the,
the,
the double helix of the DNA.
That's a really fascinating concept too,
that the caduceus is used for medicine
and it's used to rep mean it's just,
he had some really interesting points
saccharide did.
So it's Kinda,
it's Kinda too bad.
There was so much crazy involved in
that.
I think
any of us should,
when we're exploring the deep and hidden
mysteries of the past is,
is to go to a lot of different sources.
Go to a lot of dots,
just stick with the mainstream.
Don't just stick with the alternative,
but try to tie it to bring it all
together.
And in a way,
that's what I tried to do in my books
except the skeptics still hate them.
But this is so hard because it's so,
it's so fun to go with the crazy story.
Yeah.
Like the,
the alien story is so compelling.
It's so fun.
Very compelling story.
I mean,
if we found some sort of evidence of
aliens,
it would be so utterly spectacular.
Even if it was a simple alien.
Like I've always said this,
that if we found a a jellyfish on the
moon,
we would freak out.
But you know,
there's really complex,
bizarre things at the bottom of our
ocean and we've never discovered just
they're just not in the correct location
for us to be excited.
And then the other,
the other issue,
we're getting slightly off our flood
topic here,
but the other issue of,
uh,
of,
of entities that,
that the encounters with entities,
anybody who smoked dmt will know that as
I have,
as,
as you have,
that will know that you do encounter
entities in the DMT,
in the DMT state and they do communicate
with us.
And there's a lot of parallels with the
ets or the aliens as they are described
in modern ufo abduction accounts.
And Rick Strassman,
have you ever had them on your show?
You know,
rick got sick.
He was supposed to be here a couple of
times.
We're trying to reschedule it now,
but he had some pretty serious health
issues now.
We had a date scheduled out,
but I love that guy.
I got a chance to sit down with them a
couple of times and talked to them and I
have of course you presented dmt.
That's cool.
Yeah,
he's brilliant and he's so important to
me because I remember when I did it,
I was so confused.
I mean to me it was like the first,
my first dmt experience changed
everything I thought about the world and
I immediately didn't give a shit about
aliens anymore.
Right.
Like it was almost instantaneous.
Like before then I was like Roswell,
they've got the got the ship pan.
Yeah,
it's in a hangar.
But what I encountered doing dmt was so
spectacularly alien that the pedestrian
concept of something that looks like a
person but has a bigger head in large
eyes and high tech.
Yeah,
it's weird and cools.
It would be,
if it was real,
it was nothing.
I mean,
literally not 1000000th as interesting
as what you absolutely can encounter
when you do dmt.
That's the aliens.
And utterly alien realm filled with
alien intelligences who commute.
And of course again the skeptics say,
oh,
it's all just made up in your brain,
but we don't know.
That is open to the possibility that we
are dealing with areas of reality that
are not normally accessible to our
senses.
And that become accessible to our senses
by retuning the receiver wavelength of
the brain,
which is what he suggests DMT does.
And I think,
I think that's very plausible.
And at the very least,
those who are interested in Ufos and
aliens should be also investigating this
line of inquiry.
Can we,
can we use changes in consciousness to
understand the majestic complexity of
the universe in which we live?
And I think the answer is definitely
yes.
And many of Rick's volunteers,
I paraphrase,
but they came with reports that
the entities who had encountered them
said,
we're so glad you've discovered this
technology.
Now we can communicate with you much
more easily.
You know,
it's fascinating.
So there's a technology for encountering
other intelligences and against that,
this mechanistic simplistic alien meme
that's going around now that they're a
bit like us,
but they came here in higher tech,
higher tech.
It's dull by comparison with his dog by
comparison,
if you're interested in anybody's,
the book is amazing.
It's called DMT,
the spirit molecule.
And he has a new book that he's putting
out about dmt and the spirit and the
soul of prophecy.
And um,
he's just a really,
really interesting guy.
But his,
his experience that he did experiments
that he did were the first,
I think in many,
many decades to get approved by the
government.
Correct.
So he did everything above ground.
I mean,
he was above board.
He was a kid.
And because it,
because it was government approved the,
his,
his remit was that he had to find some
therapeutic benefit for dmt and he
couldn't actually,
but that's not the point.
I'm sure actually there are therapeutic
benefits,
but that's not the point.
The point is here is a tool for
investigating the mystery of
consciousness and the mysterious nature
of reality.
I mean,
fuck me if we get five or six volunteers
who haven't compared notes all coming
back who've met entities who said,
we're so happy you found this
technology.
It's hard to explain that as just to
reduce it to brain activity.
Not only that,
when we talk about things that are so
big in are ignored by mainstream
culture,
this is one that's just like that.
You're talking about an indogenous human
chemical.
Yeah.
That not only is in us but is in
thousands of different plants.
Like I mean,
how many different plants contain DMT?
Huge number.
Very prosaic ones like peas and you
know,
there's the main store acacia.
That's what I was going to say.
The tree is actually illegal.
This isn't that.
But the Jerusalem,
uh,
the professors from the University of
Jerusalem,
I believe that any Shannon,
yeah,
they were talking about,
they believe that that's what the story
of the burning Bush and Moses's.
So that is,
um,
Mimosa with the DMT and Syrian root with
the monoamine oxidase inhibitor.
In other words,
it's,
it's Iowasca,
but a,
a Middle Eastern alternative of it doing
the same thing like molecularly.
And isn't it possible in some way that
the idea of the burning Bush was them
figuring out how to dry or extract DMT
and burn it?
Very likely,
possibly.
Right?
Because they're talking about the
burning Bush producing God,
and it just so happens that this bushes,
the Acacia tree is incredibly common and
super rich and DMT and it's all over the
area.
And I should probably insert at this
point that if you're at all familiar
with the masonic ritual,
you'll know that the acacia plant plays
a central role.
That's why you're one of them.
1% Mason characters.
Everyone now,
every now allows insider.
Every now and then on facebook Randall,
I get accused of being a free mason.
Hancock is a freemason.
That's not as exciting as that.
It explains everything.
I know lots of free masons.
I spoken in Masonic Lodges,
but I'm an author and they belong to
clubs.
You know,
I went to a fee,
I went to a wedding that my friend
Duncan trussell was performing at and
for these two satanists and like 2003
and to this day it was,
what's the one of the lovies?
Anton Levay or Stanton Levay,
whatever is his son.
And his son got married.
It was some young hedonist,
you know,
and they call themselves satanists and
a,
so dunkin performed at this a wedding
and I went there.
To this day,
I get fucking tweets about being a
satanist.
So I can't join your little club pal.
I can't go into your masons.
I need to confess here.
Yes.
You didn't realize this,
but I secretly initiated you.
Oh my God.
Oh,
you're in.
So you get in.
How do you still feel the initiated
somebody?
Can you do that for real?
No,
I'm scared.
I sort of did sort of,
so you could get him in if you want it
to though,
right?
If you know the people,
of course you even you joe.
I don't think so.
It's on helping,
bro.
I,
I met a couple of masons.
They're very cool.
Well,
most masons don't really understand the
corpus of symbolism.
That's that they're sitting on top of,
I got to say that not to get off on the
free masons,
but same thing.
There's a mass of symbolism and that's
the whole,
that's,
that's the thing that they are
custodians of and most of them don't
have a clue what it means.
But near doing an important job by
preserving this corpus of symbolism
through the,
through the layout of the lodge,
the,
um,
the meaning of every component in the
lodge because it's a purely astronomical
allegory.
And then you have the masonic carpets
and that's where you have the whole
story of the comet,
the flood.
It's all there.
The acacia plant,
it's all there.
It's all,
correct me if I'm wrong,
but it's,
it's all,
uh,
also an integral part of how Washington
DC was designed.
Is that true?
Yeah,
to some extent.
I haven't,
you know,
I honestly haven't studied that.
What I've seen is that there's a,
there's a bunch of videos we could watch
it where they started.
Describe how the layout,
you know,
is in some way some sort of sacred
geometry.
I think what it's based on.
Free masons were massively involved in
the construction of Washington as they
were as many great cities and city I
lived in England has got,
you know the major masonic architecture.
So is it like people like me,
like my initial prejudice,
I hear something like the Mason was like
up fucking dudes in a cult.
Get outta here,
leave me alone.
Like we,
we assume that all groups of people that
follow anything somehow or another a
wacky Mason's in my opinion,
they're largely a drinking club for men.
Mainly that's what it is women in at
all.
But they,
you can make special arrangements to
bring women into my life.
When I've given a talk in a lodge,
I've given talks in two or three lodges
been asked to do so then they make a
special ceremony to allow my wife Santha
to coming cause I won't go anywhere
without Santa's.
So women can,
women can go in,
but then there are more,
there are others within masonry who are
pursuing deeply esoteric interest and
exploring the mysteries and you can have
incredible conversations and facet and
it's just another,
another group of people who you know are
doing,
uh,
doing their thing.
It's not for me.
I wouldn't join,
I don't,
I would lose.
I think if I joined free masonry it
would,
we can meet as an author I think.
I think I'm better able to comment on
these things by not being a member of
any such.
Great.
That's interesting.
Why do you think that?
Well,
because I think I have to remain open to
all possibilities and if I,
if I,
if I commit myself to a particular line,
I don't commit myself to a particular
religion.
I don't protect,
commit myself to a particular men's club
either.
I just,
which is what masonry is.
I think if I commit that then,
but then ultimately I would become a
spokesperson for that and I don't want
to be that.
That makes a lot of sense.
Considering your occupation and how
important being open minded has been to
your life.
It's vital.
It's absolutely,
absolutely without it.
How could you have ever done
fingerprints of the gods?
I could not.
I mean the,
the,
the thing,
the initial thing where,
uh,
you were telling me about Ethiopia,
that place where they believe that the,
the arc of the covenant lays,
which is one of the most bizarre ideas
ever,
and that was my first book on a
historical mystery was the sign and the
ceiling.
You go into it,
it's so interesting,
but I just,
I've always imagined you as a young guy
forced to sort of reconcile with this
bizarre piece of evidence.
You've got these old men that have
cataracts in her eyes,
like they were on radiation sites and no
one's allowed to go inside and see this
thing and they claim they have the Ark
of the covenant in there and like what
the fuck is,
it was the beginning of the magic.
It was the beginning of a magical
journey for me.
It's been a magical journey for all your
fans too.
For guys like me,
man,
when I read fingerprints of the gods,
it was to me,
it was a one of those books I just
couldn't put down and it was so mind
blowing and this is again was in the
heart of my fucking thank you.
Prince was published in 1995 and
magicians came out in 20 in 2015 and I
would say in that time the,
the evidence when I made the case for a
lost civilization and a global cataclysm
in fingerprints of the gods,
I can't begin to account for the amount
of hostility and anger and rage that I
generated in the academic community.
The idea was considered to be absolutely
absurd 20 years later with magicians of
the gods.
It's not so absurd anymore.
The evidence is mounting.
We have incredible evidence now for a
global cataclysm in exactly the period
that counts between twelve thousand
eight hundred eleven thousand six
hundred years ago and we have sites,
Laker Beckley,
Tempe.
We have a redefinition of the Sphinx.
The whole area is just about to explode
in,
in the future.
We're on the edge.
I believe of a of a paradigm shift in
this comic material is central to it.
What I really appreciate about your
courage is that you've also had the
courage to admit when you've made
mistakes.
You're,
you're not,
you don't in any way pretend to be some
sort of a bear of secret knowledge that
no one else possesses.
Absolutely not a guru.
I don't want to be anything like that.
I'm a reporter.
That's,
that's what I am and I'm,
I'm a reporter who's reporting on
offbeat subjects and to some extent I'm
an I'm an outsider.
It's one of the talks I do now.
It's about being an being an outsider.
I think there is a,
I think there is a place for outsiders
in society.
I don't think you're an outsider.
I think you're an outsider from the
established mainstream ideas.
I just think that I do love the same.
We're both,
we're both outside is in that area.
I'm working in different fields to get
into this,
but don't you think that these
established channels that were so deeply
grooved in distributing information,
those things have widened so wide now
where you're getting [inaudible] a
professor could do a podcast,
like he could teach a class and go write
a book or he can do a podcast on a
certain subject and like you're aware of
Dan Carlin and that hardcore history
podcast I just can't stop raving about.
But what he's done is brought
historical,
accurate,
but really dramatic stories of real
events that took place to millions.
Like,
you know,
that's just that no one's doing that
like this is,
but it's not mainstream.
Well,
what's more mainstream than being number
one on the itunes podcast list,
which he has all the time.
What is more mainstream and he must be
getting millions of downloads.
It's part of the big changes taking
place in our society that the old
structures are being overthrown.
That being thrown away.
It's a very uncomfortable time.
It's a very uncertain time is a very
exciting time,
right?
Because we can build out of this
something something amazing in the
future.
The Internet is had a huge part to play
in it.
The fact that people can communicate
with one another all around the world.
Since I've had a web presence in the
last,
I was late comer,
but maybe two or two to three years ago
I've been getting contacted by,
I mean professionals from around the
world.
I've got probably a dozen major ones.
I've geologists who want to know more
about an interest in what you said
earlier about debating.
You know,
I'm always looking for somebody to
debate about I,
you know,
because I have questions and I'm
thinking maybe somebody,
even somebody who would disagree with me
on something good still helped me answer
some of the questions.
Right.
But I tried to associate as much as
possible and hang out with professionals
in the field.
And of course what I discover is that a
lot of them are working in these things,
park time,
almost clandestinely without making it
part of their,
you know,
if I go on a field trip of geologists
into the,
the flood lands,
none of them are really working on it
full time.
It's all part time.
You know,
they're working for the government or
working for the oil companies are,
you know,
x exploration,
mineral exploration,
whatever.
They're doing this research into
geological catastrophes.
[inaudible] on their own time.
Right.
But recently,
just last summer,
I got invited to actually present some
of my research to the Atlanta Geological
Society,
which is the largest society of
professional geologists in the
southeast.
So I jumped at the chance rather than,
you know,
and so I presented hoping that I would
get challenged,
that somebody would say,
wait a second,
there's a flaw in your thinking.
Your didn't happen.
So did you make friends with some of
these,
uh,
mainstream geologists?
Yeah,
well,
I mean,
I've been knowing,
when I,
I just took a trip for,
um,
uh,
in September,
spent 10,
10 days back out in the flood lions.
Yeah.
I had a geologist with me on that trip.
Um,
so yeah,
I'm getting to know more and more people
who are working as well.
You know,
I,
I majored in geology in college,
so I still am in touch regularly with
the head of the geology department.
I see her pretty much on a regular basis
and had been keeping her apprised of
some of my stuff and she has off offered
to sponsor me at whatever point.
I think that I can pull it together as a
dissertation,
but we'll see how that goes.
I mean,
my objective was to learn geology,
not to become a professional geologist.
I wasn't interested in working for the
government or working for the energy
industry.
I had geological questions and that's
why I majored in geology.
And you've walked the walk.
And in my opinion,
you know more about this stuff than 10
fully phd geologists.
So you always freaked me out.
So what's,
what's fascinating to me,
uh,
about all this is that I think what
you've done has been very measured.
You know,
everything you back up with facts and
photographs and descriptions and
disclaimers.
You know when you,
when you say,
well it's,
it is possible.
You will go down other various paths.
You're not dogmatic about these ideas
but you've spent so much time going over
this.
I don't know if there's another,
if there's a commensurate guy in
mainstream archeology that has been
public about it the way you have been
because if there is,
I feel like we probably would have heard
about them.
Your podcasts have been the ones that
we've done.
They'd been seen by millions of people
they didn't listen to.
By millions of people.
I mean the,
the information is getting out there and
making a real difference.
You're always going to have the,
the guys like I think Michael Shermer is
very important and not criticizing him
and put that knee jerk reaction to do
something to mock something or put down
something that's not mainstream.
Like one of his tweets,
he said,
you know what archeology with evidence
is,
and he wrote archeology.
Like why would you even tweet that?
This doesn't even make any sense like
that.
That's someone who's not paying
attention to your work that makes it all
you do is focus on Evan.
I'm reminded of the Shakespearian line.
We thinks the lady doth protest too
much.
Why does he need to say that?
It's got the evidence.
You know,
always tweets like Fox News saying fair
and balanced.
You know he's tweeting at you with this.
Meanwhile,
your entire book is based on
photographic evidence and all the other
various pieces of evidence.
I mean that you're examining all these
pieces of evidence.
It's not,
these aren't things that you've
invented.
No,
these are actual real sites that you can
look at.
I'm drawing inferences from them that
they don't like.
That's the thing.
Well,
what Robert Schoch and guys like him are
so important.
Guys who have the courage that WHO's a
Boston university professor has the
courage to look at the stones and say,
this is the product of water erosion.
The stones.
Kudos to rubbish Shellac as a geologist,
as a,
as a a career academic geologist who's
taken that risk and put himself out
there and follow the evidence where it
leads.
Another one is Danny hilman not to with
judge in Indonesia
who's been responsible for the
investigation of this extraordinary site
at Gunung Padang.
Uh,
where work has been stopped since 2014
again,
he's a highly credential geologist is
Indonesia's leading expert in mega
thrust earthquakes,
but he's been looking at archeology,
bringing his geological expertise to
that.
So the things are changing.
We are finding,
we are finding academics who are willing
to engage and willing to to discuss.
I,
I got into a very interesting email
correspondence with a guy called Daniel
Lowman at Baalbek but from the German
archeological institute who's an
architect and an archeologist and he was
very civil with me and he answered my
questions.
We went into it in depth.
We had quite a long debate.
That's very refreshing.
That kind of thing wasn't happening 20
years ago.
Yeah,
that is very refreshing.
Now what about those pyramids in Bosnia?
Has that been?
What is,
what is the deal with that?
I,
those things I've been there,
I know some were magic personally.
Same as the guy who's,
who's promoted the site.
Um,
I liked sam very much.
I must say when I'm in his aura,
I'm extremely convinced.
Uh,
but when I,
when I look rationally at the,
at the so-called Pyramids,
I don't think there are pyramids.
I think they're hills.
I did spend with Sam showing me around,
I did spend three days in Bosnia looking
at the so called Pyramid of the Sun,
the Pyramid of the moon.
They love pyramid and so on and so
forth.
I do see that,
uh,
a tourist industry has built up around
this and it's a fabulously beautiful,
intriguing site.
Massive,
beautiful mountainous place.
But they are hills.
They are not pyramids.
Impression is,
given that there are tunnels,
passageways inside the pyramids,
that's not true.
The passageways are about two,
two and a half kilometers away.
They're very low tech.
Um,
I,
I just don't,
I just don't see it.
And for that reason,
I did not cover the Bosnian pyramids and
magicians of the Gods.
I'm not going to say they're not
pyramids.
I'm not going to write a book saying
that they're wrong,
but I they didn't excite me enough to
justify devoting a chapter to them.
There's much more exciting and important
archeological discoveries that are being
made,
like go back to the Tempe,
which need more space and there's some,
there's some pyramid like structures or
hills and China as well,
right as the thousands of pyramids in
China cm,
the province of crm,
and it's just the moment you land there
for a few aircraft.
You're seeing pyramids everywhere.
I've been feeling that there are
certainly hundreds and hundreds of them
distributed across fields vanishing off
into the distance in all,
in all directions.
They'd been terrorist and used as
agriculture,
but local farmers grow,
grow crops on them.
I went there with Chinese archeologists.
They haven't excavated a single one,
not one.
Why not?
They said,
we don't have,
this was nearly 10 years ago.
I was there.
They said they probably got the money
now,
but they said then they didn't have the
money.
They said,
we're an old country.
We don't mind if we wait 200 years to
get to grips with this is Christ and the
famous tomb of the first emperor is part
of this pattern.
It is also a pyramid.
It has also not been excavated.
The terracotta army around it has been
from the terracotta army is amazing.
Oh yeah.
It was on display somewhere,
wasn't it?
Where you can go and see it live.
They did some kind of trouble.
I want to see that thing.
I'd want to look at those things.
What put a bizarre concept now these
pyramids.
So this one that this,
uh,
this emperor was buried in,
that had the terracotta army.
Was that a pyramid as well?
It is a period.
It is,
absolutely.
It's a manmade pyramid.
Uh,
the terracotta army was buried around
its edges,
not in the pyramid itself.
So the army was there to protect him,
to protect his soul into the afterlife.
Seems to be in the,
seems to be in the idea.
And then there's a mythology that's come
down that the,
that within the pyramid is a lake of
mercury.
That there are mechanical devices in
there which will fire arrows at you.
If you go in there.
There's a whole story about how how
intensely protected it is.
And up to this day,
it's not been excavated.
That's so crazy.
How could someone leave that alone?
And you know,
even major archeological sites like t
when Arco in Bolivia for example,
you'll find that only about 2% of the
scientists being excavated.
I don't know how we can draw inferences
about the whole site from a tiny little
fragment fraction like that.
And that's the,
that's the problem I think with
archeology and it's why we have to,
you know,
consider another way.
We're looking at an image of the
terracotta army now in front of this
pyramid and it is spectacular now that I
think about it.
I don't think that was on display
anywhere.
I think maybe they had a couple of them.
They brought some of them.
They came to the British Museum.
There were a number of museums,
but it's so much bigger than I thought
it was.
Yeah.
I mean there's,
I mean,
how many,
there's thousands.
There's thousands of these terracotta
figures.
Absolutely.
And this period was made out of,
what is it?
Stone rammed earth mainly.
Okay.
So they just sort of shaped the,
the ground they just dug around.
They brought in earth and turn it into a
pyramid of mouse over the,
but it wasn't,
it was just massive stone blocks.
It's not massive stuff.
That's why they can grow crops on the
sides of some of these pyramids.
How weird.
So they would build these giant mounds
of dirt and then dig holes in him and
support him like they would be doing
inside.
They created the interior subterranean
as they were building the whole thing
over it and they just stacked dirt on
top of it.
Yeah.
Wow.
What a weird way to make a house.
Yeah.
And then we have to consider this with,
you know,
with,
with archeological sites all all around
the world is that any site may actually
not be the product of just one culture,
but may have been reworked and worked
over and used by many different cultures
over this,
any different periods.
Stunning to me.
Um,
I found out about this because of a
friend of John Anthony West who was here
with him.
He showed me,
he lives in China and he showed me some
video of it and I was like,
how do I not know about this?
I had no idea.
There's this many of them.
Also.
Here's one that's exposed was this
controversial ancient pyramids of China.
That one looks blocky.
Yeah.
Well that is a,
another thing about China that we just
don't have a clue.
When we,
when
we think about the,
the age and scale of things,
we're so silly.
We've only been around since,
you know,
the 1776 is when the country was
established.
It's not really that long ago.
You're dealing with China.
You're dealing with literally thousands
of years of civilization all rising and
falling and taking place and adapting
and growing all in this one area.
It's still in our eyes in a lot of ways.
It's kind of behind,
right?
I mean,
they're behind environmentally.
They're behind when it comes to human
rights.
Consider this.
The Portuguese in the late 14 hundreds
have rounded the Cape of Good Hope and
they've entered the Indian Ocean in
their little ships.
They've entered the Indian Ocean and
they actually establish a huge empire.
They go to Monica,
they go all over the place.
Okay.
The seas are open to them.
If they had come 40 years earlier,
they would have encountered the Chinese
treasure ships ships that were 50 times
larger than the little caravels that the
Portuguese were sailing in Varsha.
And know what the Chinese did at that
time.
They went through a period where they
felt they just wanted to give gifts to
people and they put together these huge
fleets carrying incredibly precious
gifts,
silks and,
and ceramics.
And they took them all around the Indian
Ocean and they just gave them to people.
So off the coast of east Africa and in
East Africa,
you can find remains of this pottery
from this episode.
And then a Chinese emperor came along
and he closed the doors and burned all
the boats,
shut everything down,
and didn't let anybody speak to China
for 200 years.
Wow.
What a Dick.
Well,
he,
he felt that it was time for the Chinese
culture to turn inward.
Yeah.
They were afraid that they were,
that their ancient culture on one,
and there might have been maybe a
laudable motive in that they were
concerned that the age had culture was
going to get contaminated by too much
contact with the generative cultures
from other places.
And that was a factor in it.
The constant desire to maintain the
current situation.
It's human.
We have to say it's some kind of,
some kind of human nature for sure.
I'd love to see some of these images of
the,
of the crowd and stuff from the chemist
that comes prairie at what,
what please,
unless let's,
let's have a look at it.
You've got that little carrier that this
Chinese parents are still blowing my
mind.
They blow my mind as well.
I just can't believe that they haven't
been asked.
It's an eerie,
spooky scene.
I'm at our recommended anybody to go to
Seattle and I just,
I just,
it's incredible how many of them there
are.
Um,
and how unexplained it all is.
And this again,
it feeds into my general point is we do,
I remember our past,
what are we looking at here?
Let's,
can we pause?
Sorry.
I can talk about what we're looking at.
Yeah.
You look at this one.
That way you can hit the mic right in
front of you.
Okay.
This is the beginning of it.
What were,
here's what we're looking at,
Mike,
right up to there.
We're looking at a place in western
Montana called Khamish prairie,
and you'll see some hills in the
foreground and you see a base and in the
background,
right?
Okay.
Right here on of this hill and down
on the side here,
you'll see that there are some coring
operations.
Those are coring gravel because
everything you're looking at your,
this whole landscape between the hills
are these large masses of gravel,
trillions of tons of gravel.
Now what we're gonna do is we're going
to start sweeping around as the video
plays,
and you're going to load us down here a
series of ripples.
Oh,
okay.
I see that.
Okay.
And I'm going to have Jamie pause in a
second,
but let's keep coming around.
Do you start seeing the ripples?
I am landscape.
Let's pause right there.
Right there.
Let's pause.
No,
I wish I had a pointer,
but if you look up,
you're going to see a flat piece of
land,
like a tone coming out,
rounded out.
Jamie's uh,
right here.
That's it.
He gets you a laser.
That's a delta.
You know what a Delta is?
You ever heard of the delta?
It's when the river comes into a body of
water and it's carrying sediment and
because the river is moving along
swiftly,
it's carrying the sediment.
But when it comes into the standing body
of water,
it slows down and it drops its sediment
had built a delta.
The whole city of Portland,
for example,
is built on a giant Delta.
Right?
New Orleans is built on a delta.
Right.
Okay,
so what we're seeing near as at Delta
and then in front of it,
we're seeing rippled landscape.
Yeah.
Let's keep coming around Jamie and
soulful landscaped.
It looks exactly like the beach looks.
Yeah,
keep coming around with this.
The thing is fractal because this,
this is the whole mystery of this,
that this happens at a scale of inches
on beaches and the scale of hundreds of
feet here.
Top again.
Lord,
right here in the middle you see a
massive delta spewed out like a big
tongue splayed out.
And then right down here you start
seeing the ripples and there was a farm
house.
You see the farmhouse there.
Now those ripples are the tallest ones
are about the height of a five story
building.
Whoa.
How bizarre.
Keep,
okay,
let's keep,
keep sweet.
Swinging around.
Stop it.
Stop this for a second.
Um,
if you don't mind.
No,
I don't see these things.
They're the size of a five story
building.
What does that like 70 feet or something
like that?
50 feet.
Okay,
so that's,
those are 50 feet high.
And how much water we'll,
we'll get to that.
Let's see.
So let's see the rest of it and these
are just dirt right there,
there.
Well,
if you dig into one,
what you're going to find is there are,
there are a massive,
okay,
let's pause the game.
Look at this.
This is crazy.
This is totally crazy.
This is one of the craziest things
you'll ever see.
These ripples repeated ripples in an
area where there's nothing else like it.
This is the fingerprints of the flood.
That's what it is.
Wow.
Where can someone look at this?
How does someone look at this in real?
You know this right now.
This is what we're looking at this as
this video.
Um,
well my colleague
Brad Young did this with his drone.
Um,
and I think he's got it on the website.
Geo Cosmic rex is being played in the
youtube video right now.
Okay.
All right.
So the youtube people are cool with it.
If you're listening on Itunes,
find it,
find it on youtube,
but it's worth looking at it.
It's what my point,
this is,
um,
this is mind blowing shit.
I think you made the crucial point,
Joe,
which is,
which is that we can understand what
this is because we can see it on any
beach.
We can see how water flows receding
across a sandy medium will produce
ripples.
But here they're on this unbelievable
scale where they're hundreds of feet
long and 50 feet high,
where they dwarf houses and they're
lying all across.
And that to what that tells us is that a
huge waterflow went across this plane
and did this.
You will seeing it from this perspective
above,
which is a rare perspective,
unless you're in a plane or a helicopter
or something,
you get a chance to look at it this way.
You really get a better sense of what it
is.
If you are on the ground there,
you'd probably say,
Oh,
look at all the hills taught to say
quite get the impression are we did
visit this,
this location.
Um,
and,
and to that day it was overcast.
So you don't quite get the effect like
you do when you've got low sun angle
really helps you to see what,
what,
what's going on in the landscape.
Can I ask you,
is there a dispute to this?
Is there no,
no.
Nobody disputes it.
Nobody knows from a flood.
Not Anymore.
Wow.
No.
In fact,
it was this j t party,
nobody disputes that.
It was caused by massive waterflows.
Those same people would still not buy
into the notion that there was this one
humongous flood.
Okay.
So they think it's an accumulative
effect,
but that this was all created towards
the bottom of Lake Missoula,
right?
Yeah.
And this was supposed to actually
represent the draining of lake missoula.
Right.
Whereas I argue from a number of
different reasons that this is the
filling missoula.
I have a friend of mine who,
uh,
his friend lives in Montana and they
found a dinosaur on his ranch.
Allow,
yeah.
Like really recently.
That's a nice thing to find.
We should come back to that because
there's a connection here.
Yeah.
The,
well,
the Great Western inland sea,
all that,
that area there was,
I mean this is a crazy place at one
point in time.
It's still is,
I'll give it a different way.
The water here,
Joe,
that did this,
the way to visualize this is to again,
begin to think a tsunami.
You have to think tsunami because it's a
tsunami is the closest scale of water
flow that we've experienced in,
in modern times.
No river flood.
His even approached this,
right?
No,
no,
no flooding,
any flood plain,
nothing that we can put into
perspective.
The closest,
the closest we can get to it as this is
a tsunami,
but even there you got to picture the
tsunamis that we've experienced in the
last decade and a half and you know in,
in Indonesia,
in Japan when they made landfall,
both tsunamis were roughly between 20
and 50 feet depending on where you were
relative to the,
to the oncoming wave and how far
distance you were from it.
Here what you have to visualize is a
tsunami
sweeping over the land that's over a
thousand feet deep.
That's,
that's what happened here.
And we know that because we can trace
the,
the high water marks on the hillsides
are clearly left.
The high water marks are clearly etched
into the,
into the hillsides.
So we now know based upon the study of
the ripples in the water here was moving
down,
it's filling this base and it's rushing
in and a great tsunami from the north of
freshwater melt water coming off the ice
sheet and it's sweeping down over this
land.
It probably two or 300 million cubic
feet per second,
which is an inconceivable amount of
water.
It's,
it's many times in excess of every river
flowing on earth flowing today all at
once.
It's,
it's beyond that many times,
10 or 20 times beyond that one of the
trip you're things about water is that
water in in itself?
It's kind of fractal on some sort of a
weird way.
When you look at the,
the,
the actual molecules of water,
it's almost like we don't do,
we don't distinguish it as being a
fractal thing cause we see it as like
this moving flowing.
But if you're looking at the actual
molecules of water,
a cup of water with that,
you dip your fingers in,
which is seemingly completely innocuous,
becomes this massive element of change.
When the volume is a thousand feet high
and it's rolling over with massive
amounts of weight behind them,
it's that same stuff.
Massive amounts of weight,
enough enough voice that it's actually
causing seismic responses in only
imagine how much weight are you talking
about?
Let's get can create these 50 foot high
walls.
But this what's fascinating to me is
that we don't have,
we,
we don't have a scale like in our minds
as a reference,
like the difference between that Little
Cup and these gigantic waves that,
uh,
you,
you see that a surfer's a travel by jet
ski to get to,
you know,
the off of a,
uh,
I believe it's Mexico,
right?
You ever seen those massive ways they go
way out,
miles out to get to these crazy waves
and we ride them in that like 60,
70 feet high.
Like that's,
that's the comparison.
Almost like a glass of water to those
waves.
And then that to this scales up,
it scales up,
it scales up and at a certain point it
can change.
The whole story of civilization almost
doesn't compute.
You can intellectualize it,
but it's almost not computing.
One of these flood flows here is three
orders of magnitude greater than the
largest measured modern flood.
In other words,
over a thousand times greater in terms
of peak discharge or volume,
you would have to scale up at least a
thousand times greater than any modern
measured flood to get to the smallest.
Really of these flows here cause this
is,
this is just one re one place,
one locale of an five states where you
can trace the,
the literally the,
the uh,
an ocean of fresh water sweeping across
the Pacific northwest.
Pretty much washing away anything that
was there.
It's almost like we have a defense
mechanism built in where we ignore how
vulnerable we really are.
Like we put it maybe that's one of the
reasons why people are so reluctant to
really go deep into studying asteroidal
impacts.
I think it was,
or even to pay attention to this,
stuff like that.
This could happen and this is,
I mean it does enough to separate
subjects because this is the result of
the comment impact on the,
on the ice cap.
This is,
this is the,
this is why I feel that the research in
this field is so vital.
Okay.
Right there.
Yeah.
Now here,
notice this is Craig.
That's a beach.
It's a beach.
It's a beach for giant monsters is what
it is.
You can see in this here that you've
actually got three massive currents
converging here.
Do you see that over here on the right,
you've got a massive current coming in
that would be uh,
from the west and then we're standing.
We would be standing looking down
current of course this,
the,
um,
the drone I'm guessing here is about 200
feet in elevation.
So the top of the water was another
eight to 900 feet above this perspective
right here and it's moving very,
very fast and it's sweeping down into a
river valley that's down in those
mountains you see in the distance.
And from there it's being carried down
in joining up other equally as large
floods coming in from other valleys.
And all of this is happening at once and
it's covering five states basically.
And that's just one region that's being
affected by this sudden catastrophic
melting of the ice sheet.
They are dealing with the largest flood
that ever occurred on earth.
It's the simplest,
yeah,
this is insane.
I mean,
it's insane.
Look at just how large here in North
America and it happened 12,800
years ago and it's story has yet to be
fully told isn't impossible.
There was something larger before,
like a the 65 million year ago,
one that hit the Yucatan.
Like what?
You know,
what kind of an impact did that have?
Well it actually,
cause if,
if different kind of happened 12,000
years ago,
we wouldn't be having,
none of us would.
Yeah,
that'd be a wrap,
right?
Yeah.
That was a single lodge objective about
six miles wide.
That was,
that was a much more devastating impact
then the impact of 12,800
years ago,
but nevertheless,
those impacts of 12,800
years ago were really,
really bad and they did stuff like this
and anything that was in the way of
this,
of these massive flows of water would
have been rubbed completely from the
story.
He makes sense.
Here's the thing that the Michael
Shermer is don't get,
when you understand the extent of this,
the scale of this phenomena in the
severity,
the inconceivable severity of this in
the aftermath of an event like this,
what would remain of a,
of a city of Villi
refrigerator?
No,
not a goddamn thing.
Nothing.
Nothing would exist in the aftermath of
this and most things wouldn't exist.
I mean,
you find like an old refrigerator or a
car up on blocks and someone's backyard
and the south and it seemed good.
1970s in the the,
the rot has gotten into a frame.
The H is going to eat it.
Nature's eating it up just in a couple
of decades.
Right.
What's it going to be like in a couple
of thousand years?
It should not be surprised about how
little we really know about our pos.
This is also a comfort game,
but our kill,
oh yeah,
we've got the past all worked out.
We understand it.
Here is what we teach in schools.
This is what our friends in the media
report.
This is the fat.
It's not the fence.
We know nothing.
It's there's,
there's been so much lost,
so many missing pieces of the puzzle
that we're,
you know,
desperately trying to stitch together
and it's important.
I think that we actually do get some
clarity on events like this because we
still live on this planet and we have
kids and we have a future and we want
to,
we want to,
hopefully we wanted one of those big
boys comes our way.
Well that's right.
But again,
I come,
I come down to this,
which is,
which is that we are not dealing with
gloom and doom and the end of the world.
We're dealing with a problem that
humanity should be confronting.
We should not be sticking our heads in
the sand.
We should be confronting this problem.
And that's why I support the work of the
comment research group because they are
the only people right now who are
confronting this problem.
And really getting to grips with it.
We should all confront,
I mean,
we should absolutely all support them
and confront it because this,
if something like this can happen once,
what's,
but what really makes sense is how many
stories of floods there are an ancient
times and how many parallels there are
there are and how many there are from
North America?
Dozens.
Yeah.
It was the,
um,
Caitlyn,
the Indian artist who spent 30 years or
so pre civil war,
I think maybe a decade after the civil
war painting Indians of different
tribes.
And he wrote a book called last rambled.
So amongst the North American Indians.
Very,
very interesting book.
But what really is interesting to me
when I read the book years and years ago
was his final conclusion of the book.
He says,
after all of these different customs and
traditions that have been handed down
amongst these tribes,
they all have one thing in common.
They all have a memory or a story of a
gigantic world destroying flood.
And he and he,
this is included tribes down into
Central America that he visits.
It did,
I believe the Americas are the
repository that the native American
peoples who have been subjected to so
much destruction over the years,
they,
in their mythology,
their traditions,
their memories,
they keep more of this than almost
anybody else.
It's,
it's re,
it's really tragic what has happened in
the Americas from the time of the
Spanish conquest,
the deliberate destruction of knowledge
that,
that the terrible,
horrendous abuses that native American
people suffered.
They are our wisdom keepers.
They are the people who pass down the
oral tradition and remembered the past.
So not only do we have cataclysms wiping
the human memory,
but we ourselves actively get involved
in the human memory and wipe it.
We rub it out,
the burning of the Maya courtesies by
the Spanish thousands and
thousand God knows what was in those
documents.
You know,
we might have had a whole other story
about ourselves if we could have had
access to those,
but instead,
where this destructive cannibalistic
species that just goes and dismisses
everything to bits,
it's a weird impulse that human beings
have is when they move into an era and
they take over at one of the things they
like to do is destroy their icons,
destroy everything that's going on with
Isis and all these ancient Buddhist sort
of structures.
Thousand plus year old,
beautiful sculptures obsolete and
they're blowing them up.
You know?
And and yelling,
praise God while they're doing it.
It's really very bizarre.
It's a very bizarre inclination that we
have,
but it's so,
it's almost like we don't want people to
know,
you know,
it's,
it's a bizarre,
almost human instinct to wipe out the
past and just to constantly keep moving
forward.
There's some trauma.
Is there some collective trauma,
some deeply,
deeply suppressed memory?
Could be that we can't quite confront.
That's,
that's exactly the thought I had because
I think that that's the one way,
one of those areas where Vela Lucovsky
finally really nailed it,
was mankind in Amnesia that somehow we
carry this,
the trump cause once you begin to get,
get a handle and you get to get the
picture of these events as they occurred
and did occur and would have been
experienced by our ancestors,
you've got to understand what would it
be like to see your entire world
completely obliterated starting over
again from basically a bear and mud
field.
That's essentially what these people
were faced if they lived at all.
And so few probably did because here we
are.
But you know,
again,
the evidence is emerging of major
cultural collapse.
If you had a guess,
what percentage of the population of
human beings,
just as obviously just to gas,
but how many do you think were wiped
out?
Half of them.
Three quarters of them.
I don't think that would be unrealistic.
No,
it doesn't seem like it would be.
And if it was that number and those
people,
that's enough for people to survive.
And if it was that number,
boy,
what a strange fucking mythical past.
The other thing to bear in mind is in
the world today,
our world,
we have an advanced civilization.
America,
you know,
Germany,
the industrialized technological
countries,
and we have coexisting with them in
South America,
in the the,
the,
the Namibian desert,
we have hunter gatherers.
So the,
the notion that hunter gatherers and an
advanced civilization might coexist in
the same epoch of history should not be
strange to us because we are doing that
today.
And that's what I would suggest happened
before 12,800
years ago before the cataclysm of 12,800
years ago,
that there was a fairly advanced
civilization that was capable of mapping
and exploring the world,
creating gigantic works of architecture
and it coexisted with hunter gatherers
and who were the ones who survived the
catechism?
The answer is the ones who survived the
cataclysm where the hunter gatherers,
not the sophisticated peoples.
A few of them survived and they then
settled amongst the hunter gatherers and
tried to transfer some of their
knowledge and skills to them and it's
the same today.
If we,
if we were to have a repeat of the
younger dryas cataclysm today,
I don't think that people from Los
Angeles or London would be amongst the
leading survivors.
I think the survivors would be people
like the hunter gatherers of the Amazon
rain forest because they are in the
business of surviving.
That's what they do.
It's not a mystery to them.
It's not even a problem.
They do it.
They do it all the time.
They would,
they would carry the human story forward
and 10,000
years from now,
their descendants would be telling a
myth about how there was once a great
civilization on this planet so advanced
that they could even go to the moon.
They could fly around the planet,
they could speak to one another on other
sides of the earth,
but they did something wrong.
They,
they fell out of harmony with the
universe.
They ceased to where their prosperity
with moderation.
That's actually a line from Plato about
Atlantis.
Wow.
And the universe slap them down.
So there would be a differential
survival rate.
Those who were,
I would say that those who are more
technologically advanced or less likely
to survive because they depend on a
complex,
interrelated network of skills and any
individual on his or her own,
most of them.
But you are different Joe,
because you do know how to survive.
But a lot of people don't know how to
survive,
how to survive.
I'd most likely you've worked at it,
you know,
I'm not that good at it,
but most of us,
most of us haven't even worked out at
the time.
We haven't got a clue.
Let me fucking open everybody's eyes to
all these people that think the,
you could just go out there and shoot
animals and stay alive.
Good fucking luck.
You're,
you're probably screwed if you have a
rifle.
Even if you have a rifle,
you're probably screwed.
If you have a bow and Arrow,
you're going to fucking starve to death.
Right?
It's an extremely difficult,
yes.
To get clothes,
you know,
and yet hunter gatherers for thousands
and thousands of years have succeeded in
doing that.
Like the,
the,
the bushmen of the Kalahari,
less humans and more animals.
Right.
I think that's also part of the rub.
Okay.
It's like we're dealing with just one of
the terrible things we've done is taking
these giant swaths of land and made them
entirely inhabitable for wildlife.
Like cities like you,
you,
when you w how many people grow food in
the city,
then what is the percentage that even
one 10th of 1% of people in the city
grow their own food?
Probably not.
Probably not even that.
So you have these massive essentially
deserts with,
we're no wildlife exist other than
predatory species like coyotes and
ravens and things like that that take,
and then you,
you,
you go out from there and then you have
these vast farmlands.
The only benefit of the vast farm lands
is the amount of deer that exists now as
greatly more than when Columbus landed.
But it's because they've almost become
an agricultural animal.
It's almost like they're almost a
domesticated animal.
There are free,
wild domesticated animal.
Like I have a friend who has a farm in
Iowa and when you go there,
it's very strange because he's got these
wild giant 300 pound forest horses
running around his backyard.
I mean they're,
they're fucking everywhere.
There's all these giant deer and when we
were there,
it's what's called the Rut.
So all these,
the,
they're very horny.
So the big bucks who usually hide,
they show themselves.
I'm like,
this is a crazy place.
Like there's all these wild animals that
exist along with people and even in an a
game rich place like that,
it's incredibly difficult to get to one.
And you'd have to have vegetables,
you'd have to have your own vegetables.
So let's imagine a situation where all
the resources of our cities,
all the,
all the amenities,
all the infrastructure are gone.
Most of us are fucked.
I would say radically.
I would say.
In fact,
our civilization,
which appears so strong is actually
very,
very fragile.
Extremely.
It just a little push.
It's like when you look out the window
and you're like,
wow,
that's the outside.
No,
that's a piece of glass.
You're outside knocked that piece of
glass in your outside,
you know,
the effortless it is.
It just seems impenetrable because you
know,
you pulled the shades tied and you set
your alarm clock and sleep.
You're sleeping next to the glass.
Yes.
Like hilarious.
You feel confident and yet you're
sleeping next to a piece of fucking
glass.
Credible complacency and arrogance of
modern civilization that we are the apex
and pinnacle of the Human Story.
That we're the best that's ever come
and,
and that's a danger.
Mythologically that is a very dangerous
place to be when you start imagining
yourself as the apex and the pinnacle of
everything.
That's precisely when the universe
reminds you that you are not that at
all.
Yeah.
It's a very weird existence that we have
where we just sort of look at how things
are right now and we can't imagine
things being any different no matter
what,
whether it's people that have to come to
the realization that they had been
injured,
like someone breaks their leg and all of
a sudden it just doesn't compute.
Like,
how come I can't walk anymore?
Well,
your reality is now shifted and this
reality that we have here with this
fairly healthy earth could shift at any
moment that the yellowstone volcano is
the one that's been freaking me out the
most over the last few years.
Another big
issue.
Yeah.
An interesting parallel would be if we
look at smaller,
what happens in smaller catastrophes
like we've seen today,
when we look at the,
um,
at,
for example,
when Katrina hit and hit New Orleans,
right?
It was almost as if the human species
separated into two subspecies.
You had one group of people that rose to
the occasion and did heroic things.
They organized and they saved people
spontaneously.
You know,
because the government was conspicuously
absent for five days,
the first five days of the Katrina
disaster.
And here you had a major flooding of,
of New Orleans,
and,
and you had people spontaneously
organizing and performing these heroic
actions of,
of saving their fellow man and,
and doing just stupendous things,
superhero type things.
But then you had another segment of the
population.
It just went completely barbaric and you
had mass rapes and you know,
smashing
of,
of businesses and looting and in,
and just people running in wild,
complete,
unrestrained gangs just in just
committing violent acts at random.
So,
and America,
the richest country on earth did not
manage that crisis.
Well,
no,
I mean it was very,
and that was a little crisis by
comparison with what we talked.
Can you remember when Kanye West go on
TV?
George Bush does not like black people.
I don't remember that.
But yeah.
George Bush,
I think it was on day four.
George Bush flew over in Air Force One
and look out the window.
It's wave.
Yeah.
Give people hope.
But there's,
there's a lesson lessons in those kinds
of events.
Sure.
Yeah,
we're not prepared.
And we have to extrapolate from that.
And,
and you know,
if you,
if you go back and we will,
you know,
I oftentime is a thought exercise.
Think how,
how would we respond if we knew that
there was a high probability of a
younger dryas type event or series of
events impending in our future?
What would you do to start drinking or,
well it all depends on lead time.
It all depends on lead time.
If it's a 10 day lead time,
my [inaudible] not going to be able to
shoot a rocket up there and man fire up
that Dubar again unless I go hard.
Go hard to the end.
Yeah,
10 days but 10 years or 20 minutes,
then we can do some stuff.
Then we can do some stuff.
The real scary thing is there's two
scary things.
One,
uh,
if you survived cause he's like,
fuck.
You know,
if you,
if you really did survive and everybody
else was jacked and all of sudden you're
dealing with some mad max type reality
where people are starving to death and
they're very desperate and they become
almost like animals.
That's entirely inside the realm of
possibility.
Well that's what we learned from Katrina
or the other terrifying possibility is
that you leave the future of
civilization up to those other people
cause it tastes survive and they have
kids and their kids survive.
And somehow or another,
somewhere along the line we get better
and better at understanding our place
here,
which is what I think has happened and
all it would take is one,
I mean this is as much as people are
complaining right now,
as much as there's riots in the streets
because of,
or excuse me,
uh,
protests in the street,
some rights apparently,
but over the president elect with this
time is it represents the greatest time
in history when it comes to safety,
when it comes to knowledge,
access to information,
the way we understand each other.
I don't think it's ever been better as
far as,
as long as we know
we have everything at our feet.
Yeah,
there's the,
there's incredible potential in modern
civilization.
The,
but the problem is that there's also
very rigid mind control.
The way that our society's work,
it's turning people into drones.
People,
people brought up to believe that their
only purpose in existence is production
and consumption.
That the people forced to fit into a
sort of narrow place in the machine,
mass media beaming,
you know,
messages at us at us all the time.
Even the concept of democracy is absurd
when you don't,
when you don't have complete
transparency,
when there are secrets,
when things are hidden,
how can the people vote?
You know,
with the clear,
with clear minded out a lot is being
hidden from them.
That's not democracy.
Democracy is in fact invest in,
in mind control.
Most unfortunate development.
Well I,
I wonder how long it's going to take
before the rigid mindsets that are in
place right now and this idea of this
resistance to change that we were
talking about when it comes to science,
when it comes to accepting this,
uh,
asteroidal impact theory.
And I think that exists in politics.
I think it exists in religion.
I think it exists socially,
the way we approach relationships and
friendships and just all of it is
evolving in front of our eyes.
I was watching a movie last night.
I'm not another teenage movies said what
it is.
Is that what it's called?
And I was live tweeting it.
So smoking pot and writing and sometimes
I just like to have the TV on and not
listen to it.
Just just sometimes I like to see some
things when I'm just writing things
sometimes.
I know that last night I chose to do it
that way and I just got so enamored in
this weird movie from 2001 this is the
movie felt like a time machine.
It was like I was watching this culture
that does not exist anymore.
It's one of those like a teenager movies
where like in college and they're
drinking,
there's a lot of naked women and really
racist,
sexist humor and it's really crude and
goofy and stupid.
And I'm like,
this is so bizarre because they,
this doesn't exist anymore.
And this kind of film like this is like
a,
this is like Al Jolson with black face
on or something.
And in a way it's like a cultural time
machine.
Like you get to go and for a brief
moment see like this comedy that
somebody can cocked it in 2001 which
seems so recent,
but it's such a,
in that film you get evidence of this
weird cultural change.
I shouldn't say weird,
massive cultural change that's happened
as far as the where we're allowed to
joke around about things and if there's
some racist shit in that movie like
racist and sexist Shit and violence like
men punching women in the face and shit
like that.
He just can't really do in a comedy
today and that's only 15 years ago and
what,
what is it going to be like if we can
avoid getting hit by a rock blowing
ourselves up.
Yellowstone,
blow it up in our face if we can keep
going.
I think we're on a great path.
I think our lists of where people think
about the president elect,
and
I think we're on a great path.
It's a hazardous passed it path.
It's a,
it's a path where the future is not a
tall certain but but humanity is at one
of those moments,
one of those crossroads where you kind
of stand on the edge of an abyss and and
you don't quite know what lies ahead and
we can take a really great path out of
this or we can take a really horrible
path.
And the,
I think the key issue is that we do
actually have choice.
It doesn't have to be that way.
I see a lot of positive,
a lot that's positive out there out
there in the world.
I do think people are waking up.
I think they are questioning old
structures.
They're refusing to put up with the
bullshit any longer.
More and more people are doing that as
happening in the realm of politics is
happening in the realm of dealing with
the big corporations.
It's happening in the realm of
investigating the past.
We're just not going to be told what to
think anymore.
That's encouraging.
But then on the other side,
there are huge efforts being put
precisely into making people think in
certain ways,
whether it's the advertising industry,
whether it's political messages.
And so we have to be aware of that.
And it could go,
it could go down the drone path.
I mean like the b,
the beehive path,
which would be it.
Why even bother to be human if your
society is turning you into a worker
drone in a a beehive life existence or
it could go down and expansion of
consciousness and,
and,
and the realization of the incredible,
beautiful potential of the human race.
That's where it's going.
I'm optimistic,
I'm very optimistic.
Beautiful to hear because this is a time
like I was watching the John Oliver
show.
It's a great show on Hbo,
Very Funny Guy and is very left wing,
uh,
leaning as as his show.
But they had this fuck 2016 thing where
they were just naming off all the
horrible things that happened in 2016
and then just saying goodbye to this
terrible year.
And I'm like,
yeah,
I have a lot of good shit happened this
year too.
There's a lot of fantastic discoveries,
a lot of interesting observations.
A lot of people learned a lot of things
in 2016 as well and I think that
quite a number of American states have
made cannabis legal.
Yes,
that's,
I think there's a huge develop,
it's,
it's also a big,
it's going to be a big factor in our
cultural evolution.
It really well,
well it was a big factor in the 60s it
was a huge factor in in effect what
happened.
You had a very closed conservative
society and then you had an outside
shock in the form of the psychedelic
drugs.
They came in and completely stirred up
everything in art and music and fashion
and even into scientific concepts of,
of our place in the universe and time
and space and in so many ways that had
just a major impact on the direction
that our society when and what would be
the equivalent today or in our near
future in terms of an outside shock that
would suddenly wake people up would be
another event.
Another 10 goose government and based
upon everything that I've seen,
it would suggest that events like that
are going to happen and probably within
our lifetime and when it does happen,
especially if the message of the story
has been out and enough people have
heard it,
5% of the people are 10% of the people
are aware that there is this major
impending potential paradigm shift and
then we have an event like that.
An event like Tunguska 1908 I think
that's all it would take because the,
the magnitude of that event would have
been such that it occurred today and you
had anywhere from a million to 2 million
people instantly wiped out or a whole
city instantly annihilated
from a thing,
from a shot,
from space.
What effect would that have on,
on the planetary consciousness
and which with this latest exercise,
NASA coming late to the party finally
seems to be thinking about that.
What happened there?
What happened if la is hit by,
you know,
a 350 foot diameter,
right.
And after the comment is because we'll,
when the,
the probability models for a tin Guscott
type event were first laid out in,
in the fifties and sixties and into the
70s,
it was pretty much determined that it
was like something that would happen
once a millennium,
once every couple of millenniums,
then it sort of got contracted to once
every few centuries.
You know,
it may be that it's actually much more
like one or two a century or maybe even
perhaps clustered events where you may
have three or four or half a dozen of
those type events occurring over very
short window of time.
But an event like that happening,
not one that would be caused the
extinction of civilization by any means,
but an event like that that could wipe
out a thousand square miles of landscape
completely,
um,
in an instant would have a major effect.
I think on the people of this planet.
It would focus minds.
It would focus minds in a way that
nothing else would.
And I,
I,
it's not to me is it pessimistic to say
that might be what it's going to take or
is it just realistic?
I don't know.
Well,
I think it's like the,
the massive impact versus the slow
trickle effect.
I mean,
is it going to happen eventually or is
it going to happen in one gigantic swoop
because of an event like a asteroidal
impact where it kills a bunch of people
and we wake up to the fragility of our
existence.
But either way,
it's a waking up of,
of,
of humanity and that is in process that
is happening.
That is in process.
Now look as a,
as a Brit observing what's been
happening in America as an outsider,
I'm enormously encouraged by the
legalization of cannabis movement that
is,
that is taking place here and,
and,
and what it and what it all means.
Sure.
I liked to smoke a joint,
but this is not about getting high.
It's not about recreation.
What this is about is recognizing the
sovereignty of adults to make decisions
over their own bodies,
their own health and their own
consciousness while doing no harm to
others.
That's what it's about.
And that's a really fucking important
issue.
That is,
for me,
that is the most important issue because
if we live in a society that is not
prepared to recognize adults sovereignty
over one's own body,
in one's own consciousness,
then that cannot be a free society in
any meaningful way.
And so I applaud the people of America
in those states who have voted for full
legalization.
That's a brilliant thing to do,
and that's going to have an impact
around the world because the war on
drugs,
all the ideology and lies about cannabis
are all going to be proved wrong.
We're going to know that the emperor
wears no clothes,
that you can legalize cannabis and
civilization does not fall apart as the
war on drugs lobby had been telling us
for ages.
It's going to,
it's going to change everything.
And it's a beautiful thing because it's
the American people.
Whereas the American state America as a
governmental state
presence on the world stage has been the
dark force behind the war on drugs.
So it's,
it's,
uh,
to me a beautiful thing that is the
American people's state by state who are
winding that back and saying,
we will not put up with this shit
anymore.
I think when you were talking about
earlier is really important too.
We were talking about different factions
of our civilization or creating it.
To this day,
they're still creating disinformation
and still trying to mislead people.
But I think that goes to what we're
talking about before where it's a system
and systems protect themselves and I
think that they develop almost a
consciousness of their own.
It's scary in a way.
Yeah.
Big bureaucracies arm,
the bureaucracies,
they got to kind of personality.
Well,
even when there's no financial stake in
it,
there's just a social stake.
Like what you're seeing right now with
the left versus the right.
Like there's some people,
like my friend Wanda Sykes just got
booed off stage at some thing last night
apparently when she went on some anti
trump rant and then,
and people got super upset at her.
There's these systems that are in place.
It's there.
There's this,
uh,
Wa almost like wanting to fight.
Like it's not,
it,
it sets us up in this bizarre team
mentality with his left,
protects its ideas of the future and the
right protects its ideas.
And I'm watching these people go at it
back and forth on social media and it's
toxic.
And I don't like to use that term
because it's so compromised by,
you know,
toxic sexuality or toxic masculinity is
so many uses of that word in our
culture.
But I think that this desire to fight
with each other and be deeply
unpleasant,
really horrible,
hurtful,
ghastly things.
They just see it so often and it really,
I mean vile and from the left to as well
as the right,
the left is the right word.
Exactly.
And I think that we have to resist the
urge to fight.
I think this is when people push too far
on the left.
That's when the alt right emerges.
When people push too far on the right,
that's when the left comes up and you
know,
and that's when you know Kent state
emergency,
you have all these weird factions duking
it out that have so much in common and a
lot of times the things that they don't
have in common,
it's either because of an ignorance or
it's because of an ideological dispute
or a lack of communication.
And I think if those three things are in
place,
at least open lines of communication,
which is also fostered by marijuana and
it gets these people talking openly and
vulnerably about these things and you
find out that a lot of our misgivings
and our misunderstandings about each
other or just misconceptions,
miscommunications and we will even if we
disagree on things.
I have friends that disagree on a lot of
stuff with,
but we're very close.
Yeah,
because we're all,
you're allowed to have different
opinions.
Of course.
That's what makes the world interest.
It doesn't have to be we hand at each
other because one weekend is land.
Listen to somebody else's opinion with
empathy rather than with hatred or
anger.
We have.
We're too,
it's too attractive to be on a team like
the fucking mason.
Yeah,
it is,
man.
It's,
it's too attractive.
It's too attractive
and we love,
I mean,
we love city versus city.
We'd love that.
We love when you know,
Chicago is going to take on Cleveland
folk you,
we'd love that.
The tribal,
the tribal thing.
We,
you know,
we,
we've,
we've not really evolved out of that.
We've changed our social structures,
but we're still tribal tribal mentality.
Nationalism is just tribalism writ
large.
Solid.
It really is.
Just like I was religions.
Just a coat with a lot more people.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
Should we look at one more?
We could look at as many as you want,
man.
Oh,
roll the party.
What do you got?
Yeah.
Let's see.
The next one.
Back to the flood.
This is the place that I didn't get to
take.
Graham,
can I really pay more?
I really wanted to take you here.
Let's see it.
So you're going to see it second best.
Okay.
Possibly did.
This is the potholes.
Oh Shit.
Look at that.
This is crazy.
This will,
we're looking at folks that,
people who are just listening in,
you have to go to the youtube now cause
this is insanity.
This is as close a like an art for a
dummy like me to look at something like
that and then go,
oh fuck he for,
yeah,
that's definitely a river.
The river carve that and cable.
What you're looking at there is a
gigantic extinct set of cataract like
you would find it Niagara Falls,
but to use grams term writ large,
we're looking at a ridge.
We're looking east.
The tsunami wave that swept down over
these four states.
One branch of it swept off to the west.
This particular branch of it was 400
feet deep.
When it hit this ridge and what it did
was it spilled over the ridge in.
Down here in the foreground you see the
modern day Columbia River from the top
of the ridge where you see the,
the,
the agriculture and the landscape down
to the river's about a thousand feet.
So you basically have to picture,
you've got this huge sheet of of water
three to 400 feet deep.
It's rushing over in.
It finds a low little the lowest spot
within this ridge and that's where it
starts focusing its energy and as it
does,
it begins to just strip away the rock.
Now what you're looking at here is this
cataract complex.
It's about five miles across and the
water came in.
You'll see you've got those kind of
curved finger lakes at the top and
there's tunnels.
Those are potholes.
Hot holds are formed by underwater
turbulence and in in a flood.
This swiftly moving with this much
turbulence,
you literally have 40 secular Eddie's
high intensity,
high amplitude,
high energy,
underwater tornadoes,
literally underwater tornadoes.
Now these underwater tornadoes are
typically in this case about a half a
mile walk.
Oh my God.
You're spinning at a high rate of speed
and they're right there.
They're probably 600 feet deep because
the water pouring over the ridges at
least 200 and you can see what it's done
to the bedrock.
Anybody listening you gotta you gotta
look at this.
You have to look at this and then listen
to the scale.
This is,
this is a gigantic scar in the landscape
of which there are hundreds,
uh,
around this,
this region,
the exact location.
Randall,
this is potholes cataract,
right?
The exact location.
Um,
plan he wants to get to it,
which we were in Washington state still.
Yes,
we're in Washington state,
central Washington.
It can be right on the Columbia River.
Um,
just below a Naturi.
Okay,
well we saw that.
We saw that huge,
that huge erotic,
yes.
Giant 18,000
ton Baldet brought there and chained in
an ice bag,
an ice bag floating on the flood.
Carry a nice bag.
The size of an oil tanker carrying an
18,000
ton boulder carried on the flood grounds
700 feet at La Valley side rest there.
As the flood waters recede,
the ice melts away and the boulder is
left sitting there of that boulder in a
sec.
What did the people back in this part of
the country?
What do they think about this?
Well,
you know,
they're only just catching on to what
they're sitting on top of cheese.
This the first time I went out here in
[inaudible] 98,
there was the,
the,
the Ice Age floods institute.
And I went to their only location,
which was a,
which was in the better business bureau
in Moses Lake,
Washington.
And it was,
they had one room in the back of this
better business or no chamber of
commerce,
Chamber of Commerce.
And there was two elderly ladies in
there who are basically the,
the overseers of the group.
Now there's about two dozen chapters and
every year there's several guided field
trips,
uh,
led by geologists who are studying this
in their off time.
And I've been on a number of these just
to participate and get the,
the access to the geologists in order to
pick their brains.
Um,
but this is,
this is very close to um,
Wenatchee,
Washington.
So if anybody's wanting to find this on
google earth,
this is a google earth image.
Now what we're going to open book before
we leave the Google Earth image,
I was going to explain that you've got
those,
you got those.
See those lakes,
those,
there's meandering lakes up.
What?
You got to pictures?
You've got a sheet of water coming and
as it's coming over this ridge,
it's beginning to selectively erode into
fault lines and cracks within the
bedrock.
Can you picture that?
The water is going to naturally try to
go into those low spots where there's
cracks and fissures and it'll start
going from a sheet into channeling what
goes from sheet to a channel.
Then then that spills over the ridge and
in the middle you see this,
it's called a rock blade.
See that the rock played?
Is that that that,
yes,
that's it right there.
Separating the two alcoves.
If the flood,
he'd continued for another few days,
that rock blade would have been gone and
you would've had a single alcove up
there.
Now in the next as,
as this proceeds,
what we're going to do with,
we're going to go down and we're going
to be right at the head of the rock
blade right there.
Yeah,
right there.
We're standing right there,
so now you're going to get to see as the
drone is about to take off,
you're seeing the landscape.
We're looking to the east in the
direction of those finger lakes and I
guess the soundtrack,
is it not playing in the sound?
Not,
oh there we go on here.
A little Toccata and fugue in d minor.
Ooh,
okay.
And the landscape opens up.
So you're on that rock blade.
We're on the rock blade right there.
So now you can begin to see the scale of
this thing that we were just seeing from
google earth.
Well now the way when you describe it,
I mean I would have just looked at it
and go,
wow,
that's kind of cool looking.
I would have never have thought,
oh,
that was obviously created by water
pouring through.
That's the problem is because we haven't
had the scale of perception,
it took Brett's 25 years to put the
pieces together.
We'll also,
we haven't been able to take these sort
of high resolution photographs,
drones right above it till recently.
Yeah,
that's,
it gives us a whole other insight.
I mean it used to be $1,000
an hour to get up there and the
helicopter.
Now you can fly a drone around,
you know,
with the phone.
Yeah,
exactly.
Go pro on it.
Right here in the middle ground,
you see that big hole that's about 200
feet in diameter.
That's,
that's a pot hole that was created by
this swirling vortex of massively
turbulent water.
Oh Shit.
This is incredible.
In other words,
the evidence is all over the landscape,
all staring us in the eyes.
And it's only in the recent years that
it started to make sense where we've,
we've evolved the,
the eyes to be able to see this.
And so now by going out here with a
drum,
I've been over this landscape several
times in a small plane to see it from
that perspective.
But now,
like he just said,
like graeme just said,
now we've got a drone.
It can go up and see it from a whole
different perspective.
And,
and now you can see,
see the,
see the man standing right down there on
the rock.
No.
Oh,
that little dude.
Yeah.
That little,
that little dude is six feet tall.
He's not that little.
I mean,
on the picture.
He's a little now.
No.
In real life,
these are rs four inches and it's,
it's,
it's an illusion.
What's to me,
stunning.
I mean this is really beautiful and cool
and everything like that,
but what's really stunning as the
initial picture where it becomes so
obvious that above picture where you see
the farm land and that just,
it's so obviously cut,
cut,
slice out of the landscape.
I see the rest of it then as as the
drone flies over.
Yeah.
So,
and then we have what's called classic
scab land.
You see all these mounds,
he's kind of lumps.
That's what,
what are the scabs on the scab land?
That's why it's called scab land.
And again,
it's flooding that causes it plucking,
plucking material off the surface.
Wow.
This is incredible.
And then there's water remaining.
Yeah,
they fill fill the potholes.
Yeah.
God,
it's there.
You get a song.
My God.
Are you get a sense of the Rock Blade?
Well they,
you get a sense of what the volume of
water must have looked like when it was
rushing through there.
Right.
And see this is just holy shit.
We've looked at two features now,
camera's prairie and potholes cataract.
We could sit here for the next 10 hours
looking at dozens and dozens of these
mega features.
And you'll look at,
there's a whole bar.
This is a gravel bar down here.
Over there.
Okay.
See,
see the giant rep was on it.
You see those?
Yeah.
I've never seen those reported in the
literature.
It may be that nobody's ever seen really
seen him before or no one's ever paid
attention.
Nobody's ever paid attempt,
but there they are.
So how,
what does mainstream science use to
describe this?
This sort of or mainstream archeology
used to describe these features should
be geology.
Well,
catastrophic archeology.
Yeah.
What?
What would they,
so they believe this is catastrophic
flooding is,
Oh,
you just think it's a slower,
I think it's lots of small catastrophic
floods that not,
not one,
not one big catastrophic flood.
And how,
what kind of timeline are these
geologists putting on us?
Oh,
two or 3000 years.
Yeah.
And why did they think that?
Well,
because of the,
the,
the ice damned model and how much time
it would take.
See it gets complicated because until
the commit research,
there was no credible source of,
uh,
of heat that could melt that amount of
ice and close that up.
Now that's the new factor that's come
into the equation.
Now you look at,
look at the people standing on the cliff
edge there,
the edge of the rock.
Would you see him down there?
Yeah.
So now you get the sense of scale.
What would survive again in the
aftermath?
Not that dude.
So,
no,
not that dude.
Not Dad.
You or his buddies.
Yeah.
This is the crazy place,
man.
It's crazy to look at.
It's just so when you were looking above
it,
like even here,
I mean,
you get a sense of it,
but if you had just showed this to make
quite honestly,
I probably wouldn't have put piece that
together.
But when you look at it,
the original image,
it's so blatantly obvious.
Well that's,
that's the thing now is we are in this
position where we can,
we can see it and when I take people out
in the field,
what I do is I,
I prep them first by showing these
images from NASA,
the,
the satellite photography to Google
Earth imagery,
aerial photography,
then ground photography.
And then you go out in the landscape and
at that point you can start having this
framework for understanding what you're
seeing.
Otherwise you just don't it,
the scale of it is too vast.
It's amazing.
It's really amazing.
You know,
this is an adventure of exploration that
we're,
we're just getting launched on this is,
this is recovering,
recovering the last,
the last past of,
of humanity.
And if I may,
I want to make a pitch again for the
comments for the comic research group.
If anybody,
I think it's really important.
It's not,
it's not just a matter of funding their
research.
It's also a matter of sending a message
that we,
the people are prepared to take matters
into our own hands and,
and support those scientists who are
working with open minds inquiring into
the past.
And whether,
you know,
give a dollar or $100 or whatever,
any little counts.
It,
it says it's the voice of the people as
much as the,
that really,
that really matters.
These guys,
the common research group,
they need their research funding.
They have an Indiegogo crowdfunding
campaign.
You can go to my website,
press the comet research group banner.
It will take you to a page with all the
relevant links.
Please consider supporting it.
It's valid,
it's worthwhile,
it's worth the work and it has the
potential to change the whole story of
our past and our future.
It's a story that would be incredibly
exciting to be a part of.
And that's what I'm trying to get people
to think,
look,
there's this thing happening and it
really,
it is democratic in its own way and you
don't have to be some specialist or a
thorough particular authority in some
branch of academically approved science
to begin to appreciate and understand
this and you're a human being getting
out into the field and seeing this kind
of stuff firsthand.
Um,
getting it into the discussion and to
debate and,
and spending more time on this because
it's,
it's such an interesting story
and that's what the scientists,
that the comment research group or
offering that,
that,
that people who contribute,
we'll participate in certain ways.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
The future.
Well,
we're,
we're all,
what I was going to say is we're all
human beings.
We're a part of this planet.
We are pedestrians walking along at the,
on that were,
were being carried by this planet and
all this stuff is all right.
It's,
it's your right to understand what the
history of this crazy rock has gone
through.
Absolutely.
This is amazing.
Yes.
Amazing stuff.
Into perspective.
To understand this is like this.
For 12,000
years,
this story has been written into the
landscape of the earth and only now are
we able to step back and begin to see
the big picture in,
in tandem with ever greater detail and
what's emerging is really,
it's a really wild tale,
but the evidence is there to support it
complete.
Wait and this is,
I mean,
this is,
if,
this is what I've,
this is the story I've told him,
magicians of the gods,
this is,
this is recovering this,
this last memory.
It really is wild.
Um,
the,
our,
our time here on this planet has been
confusing for so many reasons and one of
the big ones is not a not understanding
how we got here.
And that's one of the reasons why your
book I think is so important to me.
Just give you this new perspective of
how this sort of civilization emerged.
Another problem I think we deal with all
the time,
uh,
is light pollution.
I think light pollution,
if I see the stars,
it's,
I think it's really a perspective
blocker in a big way.
No,
it absolutely,
it absolutely is rattled.
And I were having a discussion earlier
about how ancient cultures related to
the cosmos as above.
So below they felt sls connected with
the cosmos.
They made their monuments in alignment
with key celestial bodies.
They did it very carefully.
There was a sense of bringing down the
enchantment of the heavens onto,
on,
onto earth.
In modern societies,
we can't even see the stars.
He live in the middle of the big city.
The stars are gone.
The light,
the light pollution just blocks them
out.
You never think they're there and you
forget actually that you're part of a
majestic cosmos.
The everything about
it is mystery.
We are immersed in mystery from the
moment we're born to the moment we're
die and yet our society is telling us
how it's all very prosaic and dull and
it's just about production and
consumption explained.
She,
you don't really need to worry yourself
about it too much cause some authority
somewhere has it all figured out and no
one has it all figured out.
It's not possible.
I think everybody owes it to themselves
to go out into the desert in the middle
of when,
when you know there's a stretch where
the moon is not going to be out and
there's going to be clear skies,
especially if you live in southern
California,
you can get out to the desert pretty
easy.
Yeah,
just get out away from all the cities
and just look up and it'll freak you
out.
It'll freak you out because it's,
it's one of those things that you kind
of really take for granted because most
of the time the sky is just a,
a dark black featureless thing.
The little couple little white dots that
don't,
aren't really that compelling.
When you get out there and you see the
actual Milky Way itself,
you go,
Oh holy shit.
We'll see.
Now we could have,
you know,
every year there's probably a dozen high
altitude events that could have been
witnessed by ancient peoples that we are
completely oblivious to.
Right.
Because of the,
our urban existence because of light
pollution because nobody is really
looking at the sky.
But these high altitude events would be
essentially equivalent to like here or
she Shima sized bombs going off 20 miles
up and just outside.
Yeah.
It was basically like if it's in the
daytime and you're not looking right up
there,
that's right.
You're not going to say daytime and at
night if you're living in the city,
if you're inside the light pollution,
by the time it happens,
it's over.
But if you're out in a completely
wilderness area where you've got,
you know,
visual access to the stars and you're
aware of that and you're constantly
aware of the presence of the sky,
you're going to see much more of that
kind of thing happening.
Then if the cosmos decides to get a
little bit more active,
which it apparently does from time to
time,
suddenly the sky is now,
uh,
becomes a major factor in your,
in your existence,
your tribal existence,
your cultural existence.
Um,
especially if in those episodes you have
multiple,
um,
fireball type of ants that could be on
the scale of anywhere from [inaudible],
Guppta Tin Goose.
And that's what clue in napier.
That's their scenario is these clusters
of,
of that we enter episodes have been
bodman when we up tossing through a
filament of the tour,
had meteor stream that's thick with
heavy debris,
asteroids have a kilometer of more in
diameter.
Uh,
when we entered those filaments were
entering a period of episodic
bombardment.
When human civilization is at risk and
according to their calculations,
we are entering one of those filaments
in the next 30 years.
Jesus.
And that's why we need to pay attention
to this because 30 years is enough time
to do something about it.
If we apply the resources of our
civilization to this,
we can solve this problem.
Let's look at a couple more pictures
cause I'd like to get the picture of
Graham.
I want it too busy making new phones.
They don't have time to fix the asteroid
thing.
Exactly.
Need a photo.
Projects,
images and holograms.
That's my uh,
my contention and it's going to take a
little bit,
but again,
those are know the serious commercial
talk of mining asteroids than is that is
the way into this.
That if they can,
if they can,
if they can see an economic return for
them in that,
then maybe they'll do the good thing
actually for the human race.
This have to be a manned expedition like
Bruce Willis and then asteroid movie not
necessary.
Okay.
What's the image that will show?
Well,
uh,
Jamie,
why don't you go to the,
the,
the folder of the one we opened that
folder of Awesomeness,
the bolt,
a folder.
A folder of awesome.
This.
Yeah.
Just let's start with a one zero zero
seven what are we going to look at here?
Well,
we're going to look at some NASA stuff.
Oh,
cool.
And then we'll look at a couple of
google earth things and then we will
look at a couple of us geological survey
things and then we'll look at some
photographs.
Five deals worth.
Okay,
let's do it.
Holy Shit,
this is,
this is an early one of the early NASA
photographs taken from 500 miles up,
uh,
back in the late seventies,
actually.
And what we got here is the two big scab
land tracts that show two of the big
meltwater streams that have left their,
their scars in the landscape.
So each one of those,
um,
is very roughly between 10 and 20 miles
wide.
And the bigger one on the right is
probably 50 to 60 miles long,
or actually a little bit longer net.
But you can actually see that when the
water swept down from the north out of
British Columbia,
it washed away 200 feet,
roughly one to 200 feet of the existing
top soil that had covered the basalt
bedrock,
right.
Basalt bedrock by the way,
that was originally formed by,
uh,
eruptions of the Yellow Stone Caldera
interestingly,
but so the water came down,
swept away the,
the,
um,
the topsoil and left the bear dark
basalt exposed,
uh,
down below.
The feature that we just looked at is
not even really in Nis NASA photograph.
It's over to the west.
But let's go ahead to the next one,
Jamie with the snake river down there,
which is,
um,
where's the snake river?
Snake River comes up out of Idaho and it
joins the Columbia and then flows out to
the Pacific Ocean.
All right.
Then we got a google earth image coming
up.
Oh,
okay.
Want to order cause there's just a lot,
there's a lot in here.
Oh,
okay.
Well tell me which number you want me to
pull up.
Pull up we 1008 one zero zero eight.
The next one.
What's going on with our TV?
It keeps going off and on.
That CV is not really made for the way
we use it,
so it doesn't like the inputs.
I just turned it off so I can pull up
the next one.
Okay.
Hmm.
There we go.
So now we're getting actually a bigger
view of,
of the landscape.
And you can see the two meltwater.
That's a scab land tracks,
I mean here and here.
And then you have what's called green.
No one can hear you if you do this.
Is this,
just tell me where it is.
I get it.
Okay.
So there's the two scab land track.
Then you've got the uh,
Grand Coulee,
which has that dark room and going up to
Columbia river there.
Grand Coulee dam is right almost.
You almost had it.
It's where the Columbia river suddenly
gets skinny right there.
That's grand coulee dam.
That's the widest,
the most massive concrete dam in North
America.
And it's impounding water.
And Franklin Delano Roosevelt Lake to
about 400 feet deep right now.
All of the area at the top,
the glacier,
the green mountainous area.
This was all covered in ice and then
over to the left,
right there you have that Brown area and
do you see the kind of semicircular arc
of dark ground right there?
Yes.
That is where a tongue of the ice came
out of Canada and it stopped right there
and when it receded,
when it melted,
melted back,
what it did was it left all this rubble
that can't really be farmed effectively.
This it's called tail glacial till and
where the glacier,
where the glacier and did,
that's called more Maureen,
Maureen,
and you can see it's circular where the
glacier came and then coming right off
the snout of the glacier.
Do you see kind of up a ribbony that's a
giant scar on the landscape that was
formed by a meltwater stream coming off
of that ice sheet.
It's called Moses Cooley.
Hey Randall,
I think we should keep in mind a lot of
the audience aren't actually seeing the
visuals on this tape.
The takeaway is that all across the
Pacific northwest is a landscape that
has been utterly scarred and devastated
by gigantic flood that took place.
12,008
it's left its marks everywhere and this
is right.
Yeah,
right
near core de Lane,
so cordileone is from that.
That's the residue of this quarter lane
right there.
If people go to the Geo cosmic rex
website or the sacred geometry
international website,
they can see most of the images that
we're showing you.
You'll see it.
If they watched the youtube video,
they can watch it and hear you talk
about it at the same time.
It's just the,
the vast majority,
probably 90% of our new,
but just seeing the visuals right now,
but they can and so they probably will
so they can go to that and watch it.
You can look down way down on the lower
left is the potholes cataract,
right.
Go up a little up along the river.
Come down south south,
keep coming,
keep coming.
Stop.
Look to the right of the river.
That's what we were just,
this man knows his landscapes.
To note to the right,
to the right to the right,
Jamie,
how dare you.
Yeah.
This,
this whole area.
So we get it.
This whole,
every area has been absolutely anon
unequivocably undeniably you see this
Joe,
and you realize the scale of what we
just looked at and now you're seeing
that within this whole landscape there
was essentially inundated.
You're,
you'll start to get the,
the scale of the thing and that's what
I'm trying to do here.
If you joke and get the scale of this in
your mind,
I've accomplished something.
I think I got it from that one image was
a,
that was a real mind blower.
The right bolts.
Yeah.
The ripples.
There were all the ripples were real
mind blower and then the,
the other one with the farm land and
then there's just massive channel cut
into it.
You kind of get it.
Yeah.
Um,
the ripples aren't even on this image
there their way to the east.
Has Anybody sat down with you and tried
to dispute this?
I mean the people that believe that this
was a slow and gradual effect.
Does anybody sat down and tried to
debate you on this?
No,
that seems like something that would be
really interesting to debate.
I mean,
I would love to see someone who's a
geologist that,
you know,
the,
I'm sure there's someone out there that
is listening to this that may have a
dispute with it.
There is,
I'm sure,
but I would love to,
I would love to see them talk to you
about it and go over all the various
things.
The nuclear glass that they find,
the uh,
I mean all of it,
all the top to bottom.
Here's the thing,
Joe,
at this point,
nobody is connecting the work of the,
of the comic research group with the
Missoula flood effects that we're
looking at or,
or rest.
Except except us.
That's crazy.
Most people were like,
that's crazy.
How's it possible?
Because it's such an obvious,
it's such an obvious connection and it
really merits expos scares the shit out
of me.
What if you guys didn't exist?
What if you guys would never born?
What if you never wrote that book?
And what if you never been freaking out
about this shit your whole life?
How would I know about many times in the
human story as this happened where stuff
has just not been explored that really
need to put the pet sounds crazy to
something like a Michael Shermer to a
skeptical person.
Well,
I say to Michael Shermer,
come on man,
let's go spend a week out in that
landscape.
Well he does want to debate you.
He wants to sit down and debate you
Graham.
Let's,
can we set that up?
We can set that up.
I will love it.
That sounds,
that sounds like it would be a good time
in my mind.
There's really no,
no arguing with with this,
this evidence,
I mean overwhelming.
And the question really comes down to at
this point nobody disputes that there
were catastrophic flood.
The question is what was the mechanism?
How many were there?
How long would it take?
How long did it take?
Was it a bunch of catastrophic but
smaller floods or was it back to Brett's
original model of one giant flood?
And I think the truth actually lies
somewhere between the two and,
and it,
again,
the geology gets complicated,
but I'm writing it up so I will explain
in detail what my thoughts are.
And after,
after having criss crossed thousands of
miles of this landscape repeatedly and
basically absorbed every piece of
scientific literature every written on
it,
I've evolved some ideas about what could
have happened here and how it happened.
Well,
I was a grown adult and I found out that
North America,
most of it was by,
you know,
what was it?
10 12,000
years ago was covered by a mile high
sheet of ice.
Yes.
Odd.
I was a grown adult and I went,
well,
America roughly north of Minneapolis.
Yeah.
And that was,
that's common knowledge,
right?
I mean,
everybody knew that.
Anybody who's actually studied the
history of it,
but it never made it to my dopey head
until I was a grown adult.
And then I went,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
What the idea in my mind that this whole
thing was covered just 12,000
years ago.
It seems so incredibly recent.
And by the way,
that ice was more like two miles deep,
could consider the weight of those ice
masses pressing down.
I mean,
anything that was there before the ice
came down would have been ground to
powder and then as the ice cataclysmic,
he melts everything below it is washed
away forever so I can erase her for the
world.
That's exactly,
that's a great phrase and eraser for the
world.
And that is the thing that so many of
the skeptics haven't factored into their
thinking when you're going,
well,
where's the evidence?
The evidence is you've got to understand
is that we have to rethink the
possibility of evidence once we know
that there has been,
these are racers of the world that have
transpired and,
and not just once,
but I mean what we're looking at here is
probably the most severe events in the
last 5 million years and I have a reason
for using that number 5 million.
What's the reason?
Well,
the reason is is based upon the,
the,
the severity of the mass extinction.
We have to go back 5 million years to
find an extinction event of an
equivalent level as what occurred at the
younger dryas.
It's funny because what I would call a
kneejerk skeptical person would always
say that extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence.
Is there anything more extraordinary
than that image of those farmlands and
that giant swath cut instead of land?
That's,
that is the,
what is it?
That's pretty right.
Pretty extraordinary.
And then the core samples,
the core samples that show this massive
fluctuation of temperature and we've
looked at,
yeah,
in pre gout that coincides with the
melting of the ice.
Yes,
yes.
It's all there.
Obviously all leads,
even if someone like me,
it leads to an event and this
cataclysmic episode immediately precedes
the time when we'd been told that
civilization began.
Yeah.
That's the other point,
which is really important.
We had this huge punctuation mark and
then civilization suddenly started to
evolve.
No,
it was there before.
This is a reinvention.
Those hunter gatherers,
like those people that you would wash
and one of those shows where they
survive in Alaska.
Even watch those shows.
Yes,
this shows a great life below zero s
crazy assholes and live in those people
would make it.
Those people would make it and they
would breed and they would carry on.
Yeah.
What does that,
what does it say?
1012 you could just say it next day and
age.
I don't want to interrupt your Joe.
No worries.
Look at this.
Wow.
Okay.
So that to me,
I'm looking at this after what you've
told me that looks like water that is
sort of like receded and left these
lines and this hillside.
Thank thank you have a bath tub ring
after Joe.
You get in there and you take a bath and
the water is basically brown with
sediment.
[inaudible] the way you've taken tub,
you leave in sediment and your tub.
Hey man,
how'd your quoting genesis and the
water's prevailed exceedingly upon the
earth and all the high hills were
cupboard.
Wow.
Because I'm,
you know,
trying to pump the biblical flood model
and the far from it.
What I am trying to do is draw out
pictures whenever I realized here's a
great quote and it doesn't matter where
it's from because there's so many flood
legends you can quote from.
Well the biblical flood model is it is
one of those,
Smith's is one of those traditions that
have come to want to thousands of
traditions that speak of this.
The whole ancestral memory of the human
race is telling us that something
terrible happened.
It's also very unfortunate.
That's all that's all connected with an
ideology that a lot of people find
problematic like that.
There's this issues with that being,
you know,
religion of course colt or there's a
faith based beliefs.
We must have immediately realize the
flood is not the property of the
monotheistic religions that is found in
every culture on it.
Also in that a lot of these stories
you're talking about massive
translations from ancient Hebrew to
Latin.
The Greek and a lot is lost in the
process and the you're dealing with.
A lot of these stories were handed down
from generation to generation for like
what was it like a thousand years before
the first version was ever ripped?
Sedately absolutely.
So all that's,
I mean that is unbelievably fascinating.
Go to 1014 one zero one four and we'll
see a topographic map.
Ah,
yeah.
Whoa.
Now that you know,
it's like it's crazy.
It looks like something just wa like you
had a sand castle or some flat sand set
up and a wave came in and cut through it
and then
pulled back.
The wave came from the north and it's
swept down over the landscape and
basically carved and plucked and
quarried and gouged and Gash that
landscape and this is one of the places
Graham and I went.
If you look right in there,
you'll see where it says grand part of
Grand Coulee,
G,
r a n d right there with the D is we
have a great video clip online of me and
gray and we're looking at this actual
Topo map right here and and then
surveying the cataract around us.
You'll also notice that there's a rock
blade just like similar to the one that
we just saw on the drone footage.
See the Rock Lake and you recognize the
alcoves now.
Yeah.
And if we go to the next one,
we have a google earth image of 1015 of
this feature
and there's the Google Earth emh.
And for scale in the upper left hand,
I've super imposed Niagara Falls at the,
at the same scale.
So you can see by comparison.
Wow.
Have you been to Niagara Falls,
Joe?
I went when I was a little kid.
I honestly don't remember.
I think I went when I was a little kid.
I'll have to check with my mom on
sensitive to see it.
But you could.
The here is that anybody looking at this
and you know,
if the folks look at the,
um,
the imagery on the online,
the biggest waterfalls in the world.
What Niagara?
Not In terms of volume.
No,
but nor in terms of the African or
something.
Yeah.
Or South American.
Maybe Victoria Falls a Ted pans,
you know,
the highest or the greatest volume.
It's about 200,000
between 150 and 200,000
cubic feet per second going over those
false depending on the f,
the flow of the river.
But the,
the flow that came through here was
about 350 million cubic feet per second
and left this and uh,
yeah,
if you go in line on the Geo cosmic rex
website,
there's a video clip of me and Graham
down there just just uh,
by perch lake.
May I ask you a question here?
Yeah.
Now if the water that was creating Grand
Canyon or the Niagara Falls rather right
up there,
if that all receded and we could see the
bottom,
wouldn't it look similar to what you see
in here?
The one of Grand Canyon?
No,
excuse me,
nine with Agora falls right there.
Right above it.
Right there.
Yes it would,
but on a smaller scale on a smaller
scale,
but like on a smaller scale,
like some of the smaller features that
you see right there,
right?
Yeah.
And that's the thing you were saying.
You're right,
it's fractal.
The interesting thing about water
erosion and sedimentation is its scale
in variant.
So you can look at features and coming
up into pictures.
Here I've got a beautiful example of
scale and variants where you see the
small version and the large version and
it's exactly the same thing.
That's why if you go into any geology
text,
they've always got something in the
photographs like a a rock pick or a
person standing there.
Otherwise it's hard to get a sense of
the scale of what you're looking at.
Right.
So my,
my question though was that if that's
the case,
if you could drain Niagara Falls and it
would have a similar feature set to what
you're seeing on the ground there.
Well,
we know that Niagara Falls has been
doing that for a long,
long time.
Years of work of the river at night
holes right here.
You're looking at a moment in time to
unfold it in a few weeks.
Right?
But how do we know that?
Well for one thing to scale of it
because if,
if,
because in other words,
how long would it take Niagara to carve
something on this scale?
If it's taken Niagara 10,000
years,
say to carve that,
how long would it take a equivalent flow
to carve this?
But it will look like if you drained it
though,
what would it look like an equivalent to
any of these things right here.
For one thing,
it's not basalt bedrock so you're not
going to see quite the same type of
erosion because really what you,
what you've got to consider is that all
different rock types of road
differently.
Also.
Um,
you know,
what happens is you have regimes of flow
so that what you have in in Niagara
today is a lower flow regime which
doesn't have anywhere near the type of
turbulence or erosive potential is when
you get water moving at 50 or 60 miles
an hour.
One reason we definitely can know that
this is the case is because we see the
association with the giant current
ripples.
We see the boulders that have been
plucked and quarried and some of them
are 40 and 50 feet in diameter.
You see,
and we'll,
we'll look at some of those,
uh,
coming up in the next,
next picture.
Do you have that image that you were
talking about before of that one
gigantic boulder that was carried on
this?
It's coming up.
Okay.
If we move quickly through here,
we'll,
we'll get to it.
So go to go to um,
1017 and that will be from the ground
view again with Niagara Falls super
imposed for scale,
the horseshoe falls,
the Canadian falls superimposed for
scale.
Now basically that cataract at horseshoe
falls is about 120 feet in height.
The cliff wall of this giant cataract
has about 400 feet high and then you see
the beginning of the blade rock out
there and the full extent of the thing
actually goes all the way to the
horizon,
but we can't see that beyond there.
But this erosion goes all the way to the
horizon to stone that cut into basalt
hard columnar basalt that was extruded
basically with the eruption of the
Yellowstone Caldera.
Long mill 15 million years ago
basically,
but then covered up by a couple of
hundred feet of loss topsoil and then
that was exposed when the floods came
through.
Um,
go,
go to the next 1018 and you'll see an
example of some of the debris that was
left behind by the floodwaters when they
finally ceased.
There's the step that you're looking at
now.
The bigger stuff there is 30 and 40
feet.
Those,
it'd be like four story buildings down
there.
So those are just washed away by this
gigantic river that's just this,
this write,
this massive gigantic river moving 50,
60 miles an hour sweeps through their
plucks and tears the bedrock and then
wind up spigots finally get turned off.
The water starts subsiding and this
stuff that's being carried in air just
gets left into wake.
Just like you're going to see any
modern,
smaller flood is going to leave material
in its wake.
The differences.
This material is piles of boulders,
the size of houses,
gravel bars,
two and 300 feet thick and three miles
long,
and you're all in it.
So see,
here's the,
the answer to your question is,
and this is what,
how Brett's finally did it was by
showing that it was the full suite of
evidence.
Take an integrally that created a
picture that was undeniable to the
skeptics.
It was just,
it was overwhelming because it was every
piece fit together to perfectly to two.
And there was no other explanation other
than gigantic hydraulic events.
And,
and now it's a question of the detail,
what caused them,
how long did it take?
And you know,
that's where the controversy is now is
amazing.
It's amazing and terrifying.
But what's cool about is it's
terrifying,
but everything's okay right now.
Everything's okay right now now.
So it's like you feel,
ah,
it'd be fine,
but maybe not.
If something like this happens again,
you have to ask what,
what could be the change in,
you know,
in the human orientation to life on this
planet.
Like,
for example,
I remember the first Earth Day in 1970
right?
When when this consciousness about,
hey,
you know what?
Our existence on this planet is having
an effect on this planet.
Right?
And at that point you see this whole
environmental consciousness emerge that
didn't exist before that,
right?
Well,
I think maybe in the next decade or two
we're going to see a new environmental
consciousness that involves the
recognition that this planet we live on
is a very dynamic place and has been so,
and is the key to decipher in a lot of
mysteries,
geological,
cultural,
historical and paleontological,
biological,
et Cetera,
that this has been a dominant factor in
the evolution of basically everything
that's been going on on this planet,
whether you're looking at millions of
years or thousands of years,
it's just,
it's such a strange time to be alive
where all this stuff is coming together.
All this information is being exposed
and had an archive,
has been,
has been broken open and the stuff is
spilling out and you don't know whether
you've opened Pandora's box by letting
it out,
but it's all logical.
And when this whole logical,
easy to follow,
it's all,
I mean it seems like when,
when it comes to like a step by step two
nine one zero two nine coming up one
zero two nine one I fell like I'm a
Bingo guy.
Now there's where he traveled about 500
miles south out onto the Utah,
uh,
Canyon.
It's beautiful.
And what you're seeing there is
basically dry cataracts.
Now that you've seen these cataracts,
you can begin to recognize them all over
the place.
Now,
this has not been acknowledged as being
a cataract,
but what you actually see when you look
at the modern erosion is that these
features are being slowly eroded and
eaten away by the modern erosion.
And it's the different erosional regime
altogether that creates features like
this.
And this is a vast scale of erosion
here.
And when you travel over the south west,
that is the most striking thing that
you're going to experience if you're,
if you're,
you know,
in,
in empathic with the landscape,
which is that there's been this enormous
amount of erosion.
Now,
I'm not saying that this enormous amount
of erosion was all created by one flood,
but I think what it is possibly saying
is that when we go back over several
million years,
gigantic floods on this scale aren't
that exceptional,
that there's something to that from time
to time.
And See,
here's the thing,
this is completely removed from the
glaciers.
Any water that would have eroded this
landscape was not coming from the
glaciers.
It had to have been coming from rainfall
go.
If you go to the next slide,
Jamie went out,
which is not a disconnected element
because that because of the massive rain
out that was,
that resulted from the impacts on the
ice cap.
What's this?
This is Vollis call Doris.
This is the largest volcanic Caldera and
North America.
Oh,
it's 11 miles across.
And here's what it was born out of a
catastrophe millions of years ago,
right?
And then subsequent eruptions over
hundreds of thousands of years of
leftists feature.
But what's interesting to us,
here's what happened around 12,000
years ago.
The entire Caldera filled up suddenly.
And if you look at right about,
if you look at it as a clock at about
eight o'clock you can see a breach of
valley coming off.
You see that?
Jamie,
can you?
Yeah,
right there.
That was the spill over.
So at the same time,
now get this at the same window of time
that this,
these flood events are happening up in
Washington and Idaho and Montana.
This caldera suddenly fills up with
water and the water spills over the rim
and cuts a canyon hundreds of feet deep.
Now,
what could cause that to suddenly fill
up with water and it's completely
removed.
It's not receiving glacial melt water.
There's only one thing by default.
And that would be rainfall.
A lot of rainfall falling over days and
days at a time.
So if you go to the next slide,
we'll see what sits down in the bottom
of this valley is thousands of these
gigantic rolled boulders and you know
that their water transport it because
they're round their role.
That's what water does.
It rolls these things.
Now this is in New Mexico.
See?
So this is related to the spillway.
The overflow of all called era,
which has been dated to that same
interval when the floods were happening
up north,
the same interval that now the comment
is dating too.
Is this coincidence or are the two
related?
I would say it would be very premature
to dismiss it and say that they're not
relating to that because as graeme just
said,
one of the once at one of the
consequences of an impact,
whether it's into the ocean or the ice
sheet,
is you're going to have extreme amounts
of water vapor injected catastrophic Lee
into the atmosphere,
which is then going to rain out in
incredible torrential downpours that
might last for days at a time,
and we'll along with that,
water vapor is a tremendous amount of
particulate mass and it's that right out
that I would say close the erosion on
the Sphinx and tells us that the Sphinx
is 12,000
years old,
2005 you guys are freaking me out.
This is amazing.
This is the most convincing argument yet
that you guys have ever made for this
because it's all,
it's all been convincing.
This is a,
this is more compelling and then all the
pieces with the go home together.
Next slide,
Jamie,
which would be thousand and 32 which is
to me a beautiful example of scale and
variance.
Oh Wow.
Here we have the
modern snake river flowing into modern
channel,
and then we have the ancient flood
channel and which you can see there the
average annual discharge of the snake,
56,900
cubic feet,
but the estimated flood that created the
big channel is 40 million cubic feet.
And now this flood actually was coming
up,
get this out of Utah.
It was coming up.
It was part of the giant Lake Bonneville
of which the Great Salt Lake is,
but a diminutive remnant.
So the Bonneville Salt Flats,
a Bonneville salt flats where the bottom
of this gigantic lake that that filled
the basins of north eastern Utah,
and at the end of the last ice age,
it's suddenly filled up very rapidly in
spilled over a mountain pass to the
north and then flooded the south.
The the Snake River Plain of southern
Idaho in anybody can see the snake river
plain.
If you go to google earth or any
topographic map and it cut channels like
this that ultimately led to the Columbia
river,
but interestingly the dating of this
puts it again right in that window.
Um,
so that window of 12,000,
800 to 11,600
years ago when everything changes,
everything changes.
And so what I'm showing you is just a
little bit selecting random almost dots
to show you that no matter where you
look,
you're going to see evidence of these,
of these events imprinted into the
landscape.
Um,
yeah,
go to the next slide.
1033 and if you go down and you stand on
that flood plain down there,
you'll see the kind of stuff that got
left behind.
This is the sediment load being carried
into flood.
Wow.
So you got what kind of powerful
currents are necessary to transport and
I'm standing in the canyon,
it was cut by the flood.
Those walls are 400 feet high.
So what we would think of as being like
little pebbles at the bottom of a stream
and it gets moved around.
Yes.
Grand Scans is like sand grains on the
bottom of a modern little creek or river
set that humongous boulders.
Yes.
And this is what a geologist or
geomorphologists would call it,
the bed load to stuff being swept along
in,
in the floodwaters reenrolled and tumble
and geologists recognize this,
but they think it took mainstream.
Geologists think it took a long no,
I mean the few geological,
uh,
papers had been written on this admit
that it was a one big catastrophic
flood.
Wow.
And what is their explanation for that
catastrophic flood?
Well,
that Somehow Lake Bonneville rose up
and,
and Z,
right.
Breached him up pass and it's northern
rim.
But you know,
is that possible in any way?
Well,
yeah,
if you have enough rainfall prolonged
over a period of time,
days or weeks,
um,
that the whole body of water could have
raised by 300 feet roughly.
And then at that,
you,
again,
you would need something like the commit
impact to provide you with a source for
that.
Right.
Because otherwise there's no other
explanation for that kind of that kind
of rainfall in it's known from the
modeling of Oceanic impacts that yes,
there would be unbelievable rainout in
the aftermath of an oceanic impact.
And clearly the same thing would,
would follow in the wake of a,
of an ice impact.
What oceanic impacts that we have on
record only a few of them.
Um,
there's one up by Sweden,
we were discussing also the possible
Indian Ocean impact,
possibly one in the Indian Ocean 5,000
years ago,
which,
which creates tsunamis on both sides of
the Indian Ocean dated to about massive,
massive tsunami disposit deposits.
Um,
and then again,
this whole argument of the younger dryas
cataclysm between twelve thousand eight
hundred and eleven thousand six hundred
years ago.
The strongest case is the focus of the
science has been on 12,800
years ago,
but there's a lot of interest in the
11,600
years ago as well.
And the strongest suggestion of what
caused that that sudden rise in
temperatures accompanied by meltwater
pulse.
One B was a second encounter with more
fragments of the debris of the comment.
This time,
the impact of not being on the North
American ice cap,
but in a major ocean,
probably the Pacific,
and that,
that then puts a huge plume of water
vapor into the upper atmosphere and
shrouds the earth and creates the
greenhouse effect that accounts for the
radical rise in temperature that
occurred 11,600
years ago.
More science needs to be done on that.
It's another reason why I want to see
the comment research group funded
because this is,
this is important work.
Goddamn is an awesome podcast.
This might be my all time favorite.
Whew.
Okay.
Half a dozen more.
Yeah,
for sure.
Let's roll.
Okay.
1039 and this is here now.
You'll be able to see actually a person
in the,
in the field of view next to one at a
giant current ripple.
And uh,
there's a giant that's a giant current
ripple field.
We did see this one gram.
This is the west bar.
Um,
all right,
cool.
Yes.
If you go back one slide,
we can see an aerial photo.
I took years ago of West bar.
It's three miles long.
Okay,
there it is.
Whoa.
And there's an airport down.
The lighter colored buff stuff is a
landing strip and the the,
the,
the uh,
airport building,
there is three stories tall.
So this whole feature is um,
three miles long and the ripples here
are on the same scale as the canvas
prairie ripples that we just looked at.
Of course,
this is in central Washington,
the other one was in Montana.
So again,
you,
as we begin to place these event nodes
around on the map,
we can begin to see the outlines of a
really,
really huge event and all of this is
going on at the same time.
You've got to understand the data to the
same time.
All this is dated to the,
the the same time that you think the
impact took place and all over
that coast.
The only dates that we have that are
hard dates are a volcanic ash,
primarily from Mount Saint Helens that
date at 13,000
years.
But they use that as a baseline and then
assume that there was multiple floods
and each flood was separated by 50 to a
hundred years,
and what they've done is they've gone
from Brett's his original model of a
single flood into a dozen floods into 40
floods and now up to 80 or 90 floods,
which I disagree with.
But on the other hand there were,
see,
I think you have to understand this in
two phases because the impact phase is
going to melt a whole lot of ice all of
a sudden,
but it's not going to melt all of it.
It's going to leave a huge amount of
residual ice in the aftermath.
Now what we see is that particularly
after the 11,600
year ago event,
at that point,
the whole planet comes right out of the
ice age inexplicably.
That's the end.
That's the end of the IC at the
beginning of the Holocene.
It's over and,
and basically what we're seeing there is
that there's a great deal of,
of heat.
Suddenly that's brought the planet out
of the IC.
It does not convert revert back into the
ice age like I did at the 12,900
event.
See.
So what we then have is that in the
aftermath of this event,
the whole climate of the earth has been
completely altered.
The whole balance of nature has been
completely altered from before these
events to after these events.
But what you have now is a lot of
residual ice that takes about two or
3000 years to melt away.
So say levels continue to rise.
Sea level of continual work to rise and
the melting of this ice produces some
pretty big floods,
but not on the scale of what we're
looking at here.
And I think it's my personal opinion
that there's a confusion between the two
different flood regimes.
And,
and I'm going to document all,
I'm writing all this up in detail as a,
as a,
like as a thesis to explain,
um,
my interpretation of,
of the phenomena over 20 years.
But let's go to,
um,
that would be so important.
I would love to see people really go
over this with a fine tooth comb because
it's so compelling.
She saw amazing,
like just this image itself.
It's just wow,
what would it,
what kind of power and force would it
take to create those rebels,
those 50 foot high ripples all over the
place.
Miles and miles and miles of them.
Yeah.
And,
and she nothing,
since that event has really affected
them,
they're still sitting here as these
gigantic monstrous fossil features in
the landscape.
Now when they do core samples on that
stuff,
what do they find out?
Like as far as the dating of it,
like if they get to the bottom and one
of those ripples,
well you,
you've got to find,
you've got to be able to find organic
material in there.
And to the extent that there's organic
material,
it basically all dates from the end of
the ice age.
The problem is,
is when you have a flood like this
coming through,
it's sweeping up everything in its path,
including forests
and animals.
So if you've got a bone in there or a
piece of wood deck doesn't necessarily
mean when the flood happened.
It's not a nice layer of sets,
layers of sediment.
It's a jumbled mess.
Chaotic,
chaotic mass.
It's not like you could just go right
dig into the side of that hill at that
same level and find something that's
organic and absolutely dated it to that
cause that's all stone,
right?
Right.
It's Boulder's.
It's,
yeah.
If you saw a cross section of one of
those ripples,
it's,
it's just a jumbled,
chaotic mess of everything from the
finest sand and silt up to boulders,
the size of cars and even houses and
stuff.
Just yeah.
That's so crazy.
Go to 10 41 and we'll see an interesting
uh,
artist's rendition by um,
Edward Rio who did all the illustrations
for the jewels,
original Jules Verne books and he did a
version for an,
a straw straw geology text.
Um,
what was the guy's name is skipping me
right now,
but I thought it was an interesting
image because it basically shows an
event on the scale of what we're talking
about.
And what's interesting here is you see
that the torrents are carrying icebergs
and in this one iceberg and the
foreground,
I call it grams rock.
From now on,
it's going to be,
I have officially turned named Greg is
carrying a gigantic grant and I are,
we're talking about it now.
It's great because I went and climbed
that no longer there when acci erratic
gray.
Erratic.
Oh,
I'm on it driving.
Thank you.
Okay,
so we've got the grant already coming up
in about three images.
So let's go to the next one,
10 42 and this is basically another key
piece of evidence is strewn for
thousands of square miles throughout the
path of the flood.
You have these gigantic boulders and
these are being carried aboard iceberg.
So let me,
let me describe what we're looking at
right now because this is a person.
Is that you there?
Uh,
I took the picture.
So it's two of my fellow travelers.
Okay.
Normal sized people and you know,
whatever.
Six feet tall and,
and bounce them on top of each other.
1218.
You're looking at probably the least 35
40 feet tall,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
And Yeah,
and wider.
Wider than it is tall.
Oh yeah.
It's 60 feet wide.
Does,
that's insane.
And that was carried by water.
It was carried.
It was carried on icebergs in the water.
Oh my God.
This flood is not just water.
It's,
it's,
it's huge.
Thousands of icebergs.
It's far strips up by their moods.
It's a jumbling mass of powerful erosive
flow.
Amazing.
Thousands of megafauna are done down.
In fact,
a lot of the,
there've been a lot of a mammoth remains
found in missoula flood sediments,
particularly in the Willamette valley.
Okay.
Let's go to the next image.
There we go.
This is,
I like out in the middle of the prayer.
You again,
you've got thousands of these things.
I'll tell you what.
I'm a chicken.
I wouldn't stand right there.
I think that thing's gonna roll on top
of you.
That would be a wrap son.
Yeah.
This is known as yeager raw.
That thing's huge and is that you want
to need there?
No,
that's one of my tribe.
I took the picture and tell them.
Stand there.
Yeah.
I said stand here and then I had the
other guys go around the back rock push
on it.
This thing has kind of hanging off the
side of that hill the way some of those
Hollywood hills houses are the ones that
are on stilts that that rounded massive
stuff that it's sitting in.
It's called the Berg mound,
and you see these icebergs are not clean
ice,
they're dirty,
they're filled with gravel and debris.
So when a Berg Berg,
it's being carried into flood and the
flood waters subside,
the burgs get stranded in the land,
they then melt.
And if there's no boulder,
there's just a mound.
If there's no gigantic boulder,
But if there is a gigantic boulder being
carried aboard the iceberg,
it will be sitting in a Burg mound like
you see.
Right.
That's amazing.
So that white line that we see,
it was where the iceberg was when it
deposited that thing,
then it just melted from there.
No,
that's actually a bedding plane between
two different kinds of basalt.
Oh,
okay.
So the mound itself below it is what
you're saying is the Berg mound,
that's the Berg mound and the bolder,
the big boulder was the cargo sitting on
top of the iceberg.
Ah,
okay.
So the [inaudible] is not just water,
it's water with a bunch of dirt and all
kinds of other shit in it as well.
And so when it melts,
that's what it leaves behind.
But at least I see.
That's amazing.
Okay.
In the next image we have the hancock
around.
Is that you up there?
Well that's me on top of that.
Once you're breaking the law.
Yeah,
I was.
I,
I do that from time to time,
but it,
it's,
it,
it's an amazing experience to stand
there and to think what transported
this?
Well,
we know it was transported in an iceberg
and it was dumped there on the side of
that valley.
And it's just the thought of thousands
of these things plowing along at 60 or
70 miles an hour,
carried on a gigantic flood.
How do we have anything left?
You know,
no wonder.
No wonder we forgotten our past.
And here's the thing.
I mean,
what we're doing here is we're looking
where these flood events are preserved
the most spectacularly in.
The reason is is because you had a very
steep gradient from the ice sheet
elevation to the Pacific Ocean.
But like Graham and I,
when we traveled across,
we traveled across the continental
divide and traveled from the rocky
mountains to the twin cities,
which is on the Mississippi River and
all the way across,
we were caught crossing huge meltwater
Cooley's.
We crossed the Missouri River valley,
which is an under fifth stream,
just very similar to the snake where the
modern Missouri is just a little ribbon
of river occupying this massive
meltwater channel of which there are
hundreds across the plains.
And then when we got to Minneapolis,
we went up and we visited some of the
largest
amazing potholes,
which again,
you're looking on the scale of giants.
This is,
this is beyond imagination.
What you look at and the,
and the only the flood
explanation makes sense of it.
Go to go to one zero five four Jamie,
and you'll see,
oh,
there we go.
I'm down inside the pot hole.
One of the potholes looking up at
Graham.
So that's a pothole carved into stone by
whirlpool.
Yeah.
Picking up rocks and amend that.
Rob said,
the erosive agent that's cutting out the
pothole,
just think like a massive hydraulic
drill.
Wow.
Just picking up,
you know,
course rock and just drilling.
Literally drilling holds 50 60 80 feet
deep.
Again,
for the Rock,
go to the Youtube,
please.
If you're listening to this,
just go.
Just so you got to fast forward to this.
This is insane.
Image is insane.
Just thinking of watching rock spin
around,
drilling into the ground,
and you're talking about over a short
period of time.
Yeah,
probably.
You know,
I'm guessing you know these giant
meltwater floods.
This is right along the Saint Croix
River,
which forms the border between Minnesota
and Wisconsin.
It was probably of several weeks
duration to its peak at its peak,
and so the drilling of the bedrock
probably was accomplished within that
time span.
What I wouldn't give to know what that
was like just to see it,
but you would've had to be in an orbit
to survive it,
right?
Yeah.
Even if you're flying over in a plane pr
probably that just the atmosphere
change.
Liz on top of these flood sediments
from,
I've documented it from Ohio to
Washington state.
There are thick layers of loss.
Now euless is this strange topsoil that
came down and it's,
they've been arguing for generations.
Is it wind deposited or water deposited?
But the curious thing is it seems to be
both wind and water deposited,
but then I think the obvious explanation
for it is,
is that when you see the,
the like the,
the top layers of the flood sediments,
particularly in the back flood regions
where the,
where the water was calm or rather than
so torrential,
you'll see these layers,
these beautiful,
it's because they're called writhe
mites.
They're very rhythmical.
On top of that is a layer of this lust
topsoil with this vertical structure.
Right.
Well,
the to me,
and again without getting into the
technical background,
I think the logical explanation and most
likely explanation is that at the tail
end of the,
the final flood flows,
what you're seeing is,
is rainfall of mud.
And this rainfall of mud came down in a,
in a fiction,
many ancient traditions speak of black
but humanist rain,
mud falling from the sky,
darkness,
a time of darkness.
It's all described in the myth.
Myths are the memory banks of,
of humanity.
We should not call the myths,
we should call them memories.
Yeah,
exactly.
And,
and again,
this,
this muddy rainfall perfectly fits the
whole narrative.
And yet with the mythology,
it,
it's,
it's right there.
When we think of these,
the,
the idea of these tsunamis,
we think of water that you can see more,
most likely dealing with the entire air
around you,
filled with torrential downpour and
solid matter and everything's flying to
the air.
Incredible wins.
Yes.
So it's both wind and water and just
full on chaos,
super hurricanes.
It's nature gone chaotic and crazy on
ultimate steroids.
This is what it is.
Wild.
And it's real.
That's the thing that didn't happening
while people were alive.
Oh yeah.
It happened a while.
People were alive.
Absolutely.
Some dinosaur thing.
No,
it happened to blink of an eye ago.
It happened.
It happened when anatomically modern
humans had already been around for
200,000
years.
Writing.
Well,
no,
but the,
the not according to the orthodox
historians,
but if we're dealing with a lost
civilization,
which I believe to be the case,
then yes,
it's totally,
it totally makes sense.
Completely.
Totally makes sense.
Yeah.
And it's time.
It's time to get to grips with this.
It's time to move,
move forward to the next level and start
recovering our memory,
yelling and also start recognizing that
this is a,
this is a potential reality.
This is not just the past.
This is also very possible.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and again,
if I may say so crowdfunding,
it's the opportunity for the people to
give their voice show.
Can you show that page?
This is the,
the crowdfunding page for the comment
research group.
Um,
and it's on in the lake is on Graham
Hancock.
So if you've got to Graham hancock.com
and click on the comment research group
banner,
uh,
then you'll,
you'll get taken immediately to the
crowdfunding page.
Please,
please support it.
Whatever you can give,
it'll make all the difference.
It sends a message that we,
that we care about alternative,
heretical research and also what you're
at my website.
I put up there a lot of other followups
to this podcast.
If people want to go places,
I'm talking in America in the next weeks
and links and connections.
A lot of stuff related to this podcast
is on my site.
I'd like to plug my ideas that has a lot
of these images on it.
Okay.
It's about five hours of stuff.
Blu Ray and if they go to the website,
sacred geometry international,
do you have that available as a
download?
It's going to be if it's not already.
I think it is available for a download.
My laptop doesn't even,
I don't know.
Nobody's does anymore.
The answer is yes.
Okay.
It's not now.
It will be.
I think it is actually now available for
that and get it on itunes or Amazon or
something,
hours of stuff.
But I get into a lot of other stuff,
some of the interesting sidelines,
the Rko astronomy and the sacred
geometry and so forth that might be
associated with ancient cultures.
And what's the name of this again?
I'm a cosmic patterns and cycles of
Catastrophe.
Beautiful.
And is there it is,
yeah.
That's the older version.
This is the newer upgraded version.
All right.
Yeah,
there we go.
There we go.
Beautiful.
And there's the Blue Ray.
Yeah,
there's the Blueray.
Yup.
Okay.
An HD download.
Excellent Barrios.
Yeah.
Gentlemen,
this has been a long,
long podcast of awesomeness.
Hey man,
this a cemented in my head.
I may not the,
the idea was already cemented in my
head,
but these images along with your
compelling narrative is cemented even
further.
It was amazing.
Such a cool podcast and a magic to
entertain and scare the shit out of me
at the same time.
So thank you for that Graham.
Um,
it's a,
you Graham underscore hancock on
twitter.
Yeah.
Grab double underscore hank called,
but I will underscore,
yeah they did.
They made it really difficult to reach
me on twitter but it is there.
And then you know I've got my facebook
page and my website is the main portal,
Graham hancock.com
everything comes off there,
my book,
my events and,
and all kinds of,
you're verified on twitter so they know
which one to follow.
No,
I'm verified on facebook but they
haven't verified me on twitter.
I'm on or you know,
I got 100,000
followers there but they haven't yet.
They haven't verified me.
I am me.
Randall,
how much do you pay attention to social
media at all?
The time.
I'll,
I'll immerse myself into it for a few
days or as much as I can take.
And then I got to back off for a while.
Well you're going to get a flood of
questions about this one cause this was
awesome and really thank you so much.
I'm,
I'm so,
so thankful and honored to know you guys
because to me this is a,
I mean th th th the ultimate thing for
me on this podcast is to be able to have
people on that are talking about things
that I find absolutely captivating and
you guys,
I think what you're doing is so
important.
You'll takes huge role,
joe in,
in opening people's minds to unthinkable
thoughts all around the world.
Stuff that people had been told they are
not allowed to think about.
Your,
your show is opening doors that I've
never been opened before.
Stumbled into it.
I don't know how it happened.
I would like to get you out in the field
though.
I would like to get out in the field to
get you out in the field because you
want to see that stuff.
Yeah.
That's what I want to go to Washington
state.
Let's do it.
Let's set something out.
We'll make a video.
I want to go there.
I want to see that.
Let's do it.
That looks crazy serious.
This,
this is Jamie.
You in?
Jamie's in.
All right.
Thank you so much everybody.
See you soon.